théo bonjour tout le monde donc
aujourd'hui on va stream comme les fois
précédentes le
speed shopping chips donc aujourd'hui
c'est la demi finale donc c'est sarine
contre sow
donc sarine qui m kia qui a éliminé déjà
great chioukhs et choqué trois fois je
crois champion du monde de glisse et la
nature des rapports
exactement est donc très très gros match
ce qui est un grand spécialiste de ce
format là
donc on pense quand même
match om match attendu alors moi je
je vais soutenir dans ce match niall
sarina c'est mon petit point depuis le
début
parce qu'il est jeune et qui progresse
et que ben il fait un super tournoi mais
je pense qu'il est pas du tout favori
dans le match je pense qu'il est
vachement d'arrière d'atari on peut
parier si tu veux
pas parce que ouais j'ai parlé contre
kevin tariel hautes sphères jeu il
perdait 4,1 et j'ai parié qu'il est la
remontée entre digues c'était la
première par aronian qui sont déjà au
rituel d'une part sur des bases très
spectaculaire puisque des sacrifices
devient cette thématique l'équipement
dans le roi noir des gens qui ont peu de
c'est marrant
alors dam leca
ça a l'air fortement tout
salut les gars
et la fille
carrosse
non je dis ça y est ça qui me regardent
depuis carrosse de piscine car
si on veut aussi
[Rires]
wayne on la sait
il a le droit je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé en sept parties un froid il a
perdu aussi vite
je peux juste ravoir trois secondes dans
rapidement c'était une avec kim
et il se prend des pincettes
écoute je sais pas du tout ce qu'il faut
jouer ici peut-être fou aussi simplement
ou c6 peut-être celle ci suscite un peu
pour défendre le cavalier car ils
prennent cette rencontre il y aura plus
problème sur le cavalier
mais là c'est vrai que ça a un peu
l'impression d'être le piège le pièce
pour enfants qui passent
c'est encore un enfant avec 6000 à 17 h
c'est sûr qu'il est temps pour moi
j'aurais dit sérieusement je crois pas
moi je pense qu'il a 16 parce que le
prague la 15 à toi tu as raison d'être
oubliés ils souhaitaient cette dernière
il ya de bonnes chances
du coup la partie et en plus on avait
très vite alors classé du cinq national
également
de financer que ceux où il a récupéré sa
pièce ni l'adoption en bonus le roi noir
est troué et la structure de pour deux
mois ce cas parfois
ces catastrophes et abandonna blouët
après faut pas oublier que faut pas
oublier que sept ans merci merci les
gars ne faut pas oublier que dans le
match contre le rapport sarine il est il
à faire je pense qu'il a gagné match
grâce à sa combativité il a été assez
monstrueux en défense bon il n'avait
jamais dépollution avec trois points de
moins comme ici le roi à poil c'est
parce surtout dissous qui défend des
séquelles des positions qui étaient plus
mais retenez bhl
mais mais bon ok ça sème sa force par
son parti pour ça il va la perse cadets
sûr mais après on est malin votre
télé sans objection c'était mme naima
autres le fait que melenchon
gouvernement partis sur dow a perdu sa
connexion il était très souvent gagnant
l'étape finale eq deux puces départ et
d'arrivée à défendre à chaque fois la
partie pour répéter ce schéma de la
création mais le sauver des poubelles
mais sauf que sow généralement il est
plus clinique un beau combat voire de
lui sauver le guen enfin dans les dents
les speech est généralement il est assez
rare il s'arrête avant la finale il est
précis et il pose plus trop à la maca
mourra notamment et la carson donc
maintenant c'est vraiment le grand
favori la date de ce match
il est particulièrement fort dans ses
pensées blessés dans ce format donc
bon ça serait une surprise que nous
sommes une passe ce match du coup
pousser un moment le suspense ouais
c'est clair cette partie là par exemple
elle commence très mal ok attention à
d'un point m21 pétri de menacer tu vas
trop loin bon c'est vrai
ça marche 3c le pire coup je crois que
c'est le seul qui perd vraiment j'aurais
d'un premier peloton point m 2 tours
mais bon ça ne marche pas
malheureusement salut alliages affinés
tactiquement et oui je vais chez moi il
est à 22 heures chez moi il est 18
heures donc du coût effectif j'ai l'oeil
[Musique]
réveiller ouais plus vive
voix qu'il avait très vite
fléchissait
ouais alors moi j'ai marqué niall parce
que parce que j'ai vu que sur pièces
comme c'était marqué comme ça
et apparemment donc pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas histoire donc moi je
la connaissais pas d'ailleurs et
apparemment ça arrive en anglais ça veut
dire un truc
st-gall
ça aurait fait annuler pour toi
inodore
explications microsoft a utilisé
par le syndicat ne se
pose pas trop employés je croise sur
twitter
des réseaux sociaux et si des gens
bref toujours dire qu'on sait pas si on
va dire des jaloux c'est
parce que c'est vrai que là en bas sur
le ce sur l'écran voyais que marquez gm
ni râlent contre gm saut et sauces et
maxime famille et népalaises ton prénom
donc moi je me suis fait la réflexion il
tiens pourquoi c'est comme ça mais bon
bah du coup c'est comme ça mais
ouais c'est la demi-finale pour répondre
ajoute la première demi finale la
deuxième
jeudi à
23h être un petit peu tard un horaire
pensée pour la coupe du monde
n'a
pas pris en grippe les mots quand il ya
un replay toujours possible aussi mais
bon c'est cci
c'est moins bien alors c'est nathan vous
êtes me tend ses généraux c'est comme
justes mais
j'ai aussi oublié parce qu'on m'a dit
bonjour c'était wgm pas de chance je
crois salut à toi
les dictatures cette option mois notre
ami
même ce jeudi je crois qu'on est des
soeurs
couche tard j'allais dire même date que
chez moi il sera 19h30 quand je commence
mal ça pour moi je suis moi je finis à
23h30 ça va mais c'est vrai que pour toi
ça va être un peu plus dire
dès la finale ne sait même pas quand est
ce que bon c'est pas qu'ils jouent donc
évidemment n'y a pas d'horaire encore
parce que deux bords certains mais bon
on se cale à kiryat il y aller très très
loin
je pense qu'il a peut-être raison
ça va ça va pertinents c'est rémy
facilement mais quand on voit qu'il est
50 coup de leur a gagné cette position
qui est à + 10 après dj maréval
tour la résilience
assez à l'aise qu'au quart ok
ça marche
elle explique ainsi que wrc grand maître
ouais le plan je crois qu'il assume un
achat je crois qu'il a su
ouais
je crois que c'est un garçon gamme alex
picard
cette finale jean claude
a fait chaud ils abandonner son tir
bloqué pour
dames en fait j'ai à perdre parce que là
ça commence à pousser les pions et c'est
vraiment un tournemain il pourra
toujours venir ça qu'est la tour à la
fin et puis on se rend trois ans et
enfin ça c'est ça à faire
je pense que maintient les collectionne
mais bon ça ne va pas trop même sagan du
style pour elle a gagné cette partie
[Rires]
le match fini vers 10 heures du matin ne
sais pas si tu seras encore éveillés
hôpitaux
ouais alors j'avais oublié qu'en fait
saut il parle il parle tout seul pendant
qu'il vous fait l'arbitré leur a demandé
de garder le micro
allumée et elettrica mes sauts parle en
fait insupportable non c'est vrai
nom mais il parle tout seul et il
faisait la même chose le match contre
kawana et et bah je pense que du coup ça
arrive maintenant tendre je pense
bah je suis pas sûr parce qu'en fait et
dit qu'il faut en fait la vie de vouloir
par d'accord oui mais ils peuvent me
rousseau
va la perdre
ok abandon non il ya plus rien à faire
mais bon ok ok il s'évade sus
3 donc s'amuser un coquard famille c'est
de la racaille des banlieues quand
racaille de deux
solutions de clermont ferrand
oui
donc là ok ici la vie secrète on va peut
être
être drôle ses cadres des quatre faces b
4 et 7 juin grandi venco avec avec les
blancs
qu'avais je croise un peu bizarre c'est
que free
génial benko donc pour faire avec un pic
en elle qu'un petit en avance c'est pas
mal
mais alors c'est dans son match contre
contrant rapport
je parle de sarine il n'y avait pas
vraiment de base théorique j'ai plein de
trucs avec b3 à b2 il citant certaines
théories pour taux d'échec est là on
voit qu'il fait un peu la même chose
parce qu'il joue un peu bizarrement la
whey
avec le hca c'est la plus logique avec
fois 6-1 et cavaliers là j'arrive pas
très parlant avec alive est sain qui
peut arriver aussi alors si la mise là
il ya sûrement une raison quand même
pas ce que ça cache 6 évoquons ici donc
ça marchait pas hors de choses
séparent
actuellement ils ont plutôt abandonné
laissant trop noir pour essayer de les
progrès du possible et le pion voilà une
option qui en vis-à-vis avec la jordanie
avec un petit peu arriver aussi un
clouage 1 sur ce plan de 5 et l'idée
peut être que le fou le cabba et la tour
mettre de pression sur le connaissez
peut-être c'est l'idée donc à 6b 5 c'est
pas trop une menace je pense après tu
comprends il y aura la tour emprise
donc ça qui va empêcher un dame b 5 ou 1
et royan hk donc sa garde
je crois qu'ils écoutent la cuisse qui
s'y joignent les pluies
ont heureusement que tu es là parce que
moi je l'aurais jamais dit dommage car
je relève un peu le niveau du stream
ce soit avec nous
togba va jusqu'à d'anne decis du coup à
2005 où cinq ans que j'aime bien parce
que grâce à sa taille b2 donc ça empêche
saison quelle foi h6 empêche je sais pas
mais en tout cas ça ça pose la question
est aussi le pion un truc qui n'est pas
défendu maintenant des cinglés dans
l'herbe
et de surprendre
il y avait un clou
qu'est ce qui est dit
l'insupportable parler tout seul saut ça
c'est un truc de fou que
non mais il parle et n'achètent pas ce
qu'il a dit on peut s'y mettre dans la
bouche donc je pense qu'il dit ok
ok mais cas où le tournoi elle va vous
la dame canada ou défont cavalli
et peut-être
[Musique]
amenant migratoire en cavalier dernier à
s'élancer pour sa joie
avec les priest du père à la
haye peut la manger pendant chaque fin
de mois je pensais qu'ils allaient
fourchette avec les deux tournois potes
à tour landes et 5
je pense avant l'abordage de l'horaire
pour pour le calcul est en toi tu es là
bas tu attribues cette manche de là et
avoir un avantage mais brisent cavaler
prendre alors il ya une partie il ya une
partie donc pour ceux qui qui sont peu
fan d'échecs qui voudraient suivre
il ya une partie en championnat
d'argentine impact individuel qui se
déroule en ce moment c'était diego
flores accablant 20 2580 contre peralta
est magnifique pour ceux qui veulent
voir magnifique la partie un circuit de
dame juste polichinelle j'ai vu ça
ailleurs j'ai dit voir dans les bacs son
poids en vin
voilà c'est pas la même chose mais ya
une erreur je pense maintenant là c'est
une erreur bah il faut bien qu'ils
essaient de se battre
mais
by jiss en l'air donc d'un projet 6 6 4
pour contrer ouais
cette classe là il a fait froid la
dcri
ouais
non je crois que c'est ça je suis une
passion toujours blanquette meilleur
ben je les viandes rouges mais alors que
leblanc choix de ces deux gigots
klaus contre
pour en revenir là j'ai tout à sa
messagerie chat ouais je suis d'accord
comme sogespa entraîneur pour 15,7 il a
déjà posé beaucoup de problèmes
il avait déjà défoncée quarantaine au
championnat du monde d'échecs schurch
est impressionnant et même sur internet
évidemment nous poser des problèmes
le truc section dans l'impression qu'il
n'essaie pas de se qualifier pour le
match de championnat du monde ne sait
pas se qualifier pour les candidats
c'est très bizarre
il n'a pas joué la coupe du monde
il a un jeu et même les grands autriche
même pas sous
la pression mais les secours c'était
trop de pression pour nous assurer que
ta
chère et bizarre trop où je sais pas de
points est vraiment très fort moi je me
donne très impressionnant après que le
comique tout ça peut-être que ça
3 aurais-je même avant tu as
l'impression
ouais il a un peu moins dans la
compétition quoi
l'impact se déploie sur scène et si
ses choix de vie on chez moi
ouais
j'essaie de trouver la partie parce que
j'y tiens
c'est bon je lai
j'espère qu'on la partage
parce que
pas juste copié
chatel devient de 16,24 c'est ça non du
tout c'est pas grave c'est une base
non mais
preuve s'il n'y a pas de la partie a
donné les liens de du tournoi je vois
les gens s'y intéressent et les sharks
ont dit
vous avez bien si vous voulez voir en
fait vous allez sur sur donc en bas il
ya une liste de parti auquel tu reviens
les deux parties qui est parti qui
seront en direct et en dessous il était
parti marcher l'asc athlétisme ou thales
là vous descendez tout en bas et vous
cherchez florez car alta
c'était le seul à prédire et magnifie
pour ceux qui seraient intéressés par
pas avoir ça c'est vraiment un voyage
est question
sur les fesses pour être précis
je ne veux pas savoir
alors où est ce être venu en classe mais
pas trop fait attention au début mais
alors
ça une tête de française
[Musique]
française en
chine après le ballon du coup du
sort de la première partie
merci christophe aussi
donc ça un petit peu hot hostile de
partick que jouer ce concours carbone a
dit qu'il aimait bien souvent même
poussé le clouage eu ce courage sa
poussée de plongée et s'y attaquer
c'était une rigolade quand
ouest hérault solide mais c'étaient des
schémas qui ressemble un petit peu à ça
et
monde je pense dans ce schéma donc c'est
dans ces trucs
cool à son avantage à l'horizon c'est la
différence entre les deux voiliers
pratiquement le fou la française des
noirs tout c'est leur problème
derrière
alors qu'à l'inversé
monastique trois autres évêques avaient
lancé six pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
bonnes cases parce que multijet 1,5
généralement dans la française en
afrique à 7,4 et l'ama le rejoindre et
met l'accent sûr heureusement voilà
lequel le pion la pression certain que
diable le cavalier mission qui éclatent
souvent mais le problème de ce quiz en
fait c'est tout bien sûr tu veux jouer
m6 pour cas simples que le centre et
ouvrez les colonnes et métaux réfute 5
où je pourrai jamais vraiment joué à
cause du foie à 3 on voit bien que le
faut à trois c'est une très bonne pièce
dans un taudis ses ambitions
donc c'est plus agréable à jouer pour
les blancs sa position a mené sternhell
tapissier common
disons que c'est aux noix retrouver
vraiment des choses à faire parce que
les blancs ça c'est un fait rare ils
vont faire
adam et eve quatre tours la fin du tour
c'est un jeu des coups simples et les
couloirs je trouve qu'ils vont être plus
dur avoir affaire à cette j'avoue j'ai à
ils sont en vie
je pense qu'il va jouer le coup
ouais je parle pour s'éviter pareil
que pour l'élaborer ce qui pouvait avoir
des vues faire être simple je sais pas
au tour j'ai vu de
médecins qui vont pouvoir reprendre avec
une pièce way et de faire baver pour
nous de faire tourner à vide gilles vous
faire g5 ou justice a donc la très bonne
réponse de 2 est
ce que fout et vite c'est un coup dans
l'hiver parce que l'ex bad points 15
assists
et
5 on va essayer de récupérer peut-être
fou et 8 du coup bah ça menace g6 où le
saint qui pour moi j'aime pas un jeu
très très moche mais après on reste dans
l'idée de sarine parce qu'il veut faire
je trouve ça assez lunaires sont pauvres
ou achètent tout rejet du reste jamais
envisagé après ce soit intéressant et
des burqas nous l'a démontré
après il est malaisé de trouver de
contrôle des coûts pratique c'est pas
mal mais mais
enfin pour procéder ça lui a remis au
passage bienvenue pour ce long marathon
mais voilà il tant qu un peu il
réfléchit se trouvait un coup avec
difficile décale ses pièces il ne veut
pas être filmée par l'autopsié
je pense qu'ils vont envoyer être quatre
en fait c'est tellement facile à jouer
pour les blancs
pouvaient 4
j'aime bien tous les cas puisque kikoos
a que cinq exercices il a vendu les 6es
avec son fouet il aura je pense qu'il va
le laisser un va le laisser les prépas
jamais le manger cette entorse et de mai
au pouvoir si tu arrives pas des
malheurs parce que
menace rien mais bon je m'active un peu
proche
et essayer de trouver les choses à faire
peut-être un jour un f5 ou en prison
mais je pense que les noirs seraient
très contents qu'ils mangent leurs
cavaliers en herbe on a cinq sièges
bien sûr mais je suis toujours dans le
tchad en fatigue il est rentré fort
parce que la casa chute c'est la case
vraiment de
ouvrage peut pas ramener les pièces là
je peux rien faire ça vaudrait pas le
coup de juste doublé deuxième chance sur
la colonnade de faire l'échangé
salue ton ton salut tonton
alors oui robinson de famine pour ceux
qui ne savent pas un entraînement c'est
sami
merci
de rien du coup le tour au serbe joue
c'est juste échangé la salle claeys qui
rassemble le noir
alors cette
seule sweet par ipad constants comme
cela est arrivé alors un tueur et qui
serait pourquoi on a eu raison de venir
à l'est et passent en famille un
battant c'est par rapport à un mot je
crois qu'on n'a pas de rôle 3 marqué sur
internet due à des
noms mais en fait stockées toutes leurs
névroses explications de samy on se fait
qu'en fait ça il se serait apparemment
un gaz qui aurait été mise en examen
pour way pour autant attentats août
comme ça il existe c'est un autre qui
peut pas trop être sur internet pas trop
apparaîtra donc du coup
malheureusement on va nous remettre son
prénom les pas sont amusants mais qui
n'a pas de chance il n'y
aucun problème quand on voit bien sûr
puisqu'on vient d'un forcément
conclusion
un peu complexe sauf si vous faites des
recherches ont dit lui de détails mais
par exemple moi je m'occupe aussi des
réseaux sociaux le piège car un tweet je
vous mets
je vois un avertissement à un message
d'une attention d'écrire un mot
geely est intéressé par la gauche c'est
pour ça que on se retrouve à m que sont
reines mais c'est pas votre famille si
ça ne mange pas
tu peux dire ça situe
dans le métro de tokyo avait dû aller
j'avais entendu un truc comme ça en plus
pendant qu'on parle de garde on voit
qu'un match amical
la cimade sortira il a réussi à
s'organiser un petit peu et il est pas
si mal dans cette édition
donc bien sûr il est toujours en train
de souffrir mais l'élan en moi donc
attention que j'ai c'est qu'il arrive le
roi est un peu faible les deux voies
sont ouvertes de plus le taux réduit qui
pourrait arriver attention la fourchette
quand même en v6
est ce qu'un tour et fuite ce qu'avait
2,5 et 3,4 pour y arriver le ton est
très parlant j'ai
essayé d'attaquer un peu là-bas sur g6
bouge mauroy je sais pas encore mais bon
c'est compliqué les matchs du couloir
son intention comme ça j'ai encore
couvertes ou étouffés tous les huit
à dix la tuque strictement n'avais pas
fait attention au passage mais l'avenir
à des jo sur son agrément
pour qu'après les très rapides il est
très proche du let mais bon ça
rajouterait à périgueux nuit une minute
enfin ces sociétés
aux petits as she ce qui pourrait partir
là
hachette
gatien de jouer
partout alors faut qu'ils archi dominée
par le cavalier eric est trop fort et
cavalières fait tout moment pourquoi on
comprend qu'avec cette femme à marty je
crois qu'il ya pas d chacun sur
tourcoing 8 n'y a pas d'échec et d'âme
parce que j'en étais très vite savons
nous attend contre ton coin cavalerie
et c'est terminé ça fait déjà ça fait
déjà 2 0 pour la gagner et pas entendu
un truc moi et les autres jours je vois
que la des scores sont inversés
insupportable excuse moi dans un match
il est généré / / / simon obs l'ag
sarine qui viennent de zéro mais en fait
c'est parce que sur tech comme à chaque
fois il mettait le score par le joueur
qui en bas à gauche c'est le premier
appelé sur le sur
ce sont deux matches se démarquer genre
d'accident sont contre ou chez plus leur
patrie je vais
modifier
ça
je vais vous cheminez et oui pour
répondre à la question ou l'unisson les
parties à la même heure
même si un petit peu de retard du led ça
peut se compter en l'occurrence farine
complète puisque cette spécialité est
même pas une section il est aussi
assez bon dans un cadre qui prennent
trop tard
màj d'accord avec toi rencontrant ses
carpes audio sa fusée alors qu'ils ont
le temps avec sans doute faire on va
quand même deux approches très
différents c'est à dire que sony a joué
agressif pourtant à l'avantagé
d'ailleurs il a obtenu à chaque fois
avec les blancs alors que néral juste
sur les pièces d'une part une partie
donc
la bête à lui d'en sauver un peu avec
les noirs pour l'instant les deux partis
noirs sont révoltés contre
subsistent dans le match va falloir
qu'ils se rencontrent à une partie
a tout gagné avec les bleus soltani très
sony bon alors d'une pollution archi
symétrique
ouais
donc symétrique soit pas grand chose
pour l'instant pollution attention à
garder ses petits pois arrivé avec
pression champions les deux ouais ouais
le rapper 3 juste ouais mais faut faire
attention parce que justement la cavale
il n'est pas défendu derrière
ça va pour l'instant mais pas attention
au genre de choses qu'avant ça peut
arriver en chalosse
non pour l'instant là c'est bon c'est
fait je pense que et khalil et risque de
jouer un peu du canada iab 3e match et
c'est un danger qui met beaucoup de
positions en basque comme ça et ceux ci
marque avec les morts au 13e rang qui
tarde et nous avec les noir et
en fait ça rime grand saut c'est un
joueur qui est vraiment très solide
et encore une fois lorsqu'elle en cela
il est vraiment de talent et je pense
pas que ce soit vraiment un très bonne
idée je n'ai position avec si peu de me
dire de ceux de vie de possibilités dans
la position parce que il est tellement
celui en fait que ça qui fait peur et
c'est moins friable que par exemple
rapport dans la largement soit la même
que je
leur dise le chat ces canisters je
répète ce qu'il a dit 5à procédure
mais aujourd'hui ça l'est devenu
barak pas directement par leur chef il
parle de l'art il y parlait tout à
l'heure on parle tout seul je l'entends
alors dominant qui s'est dit ou rouges à
cesser
la violence on l'a
toujours plaisir de jouer cette finale
bah écoute sarine a proposé nul est seul
à refuser
généralement dans cette position sous de
même couleur on va vouloir mettre les
pions sur la couleur inverse de son
saoul pour park options soit soit faible
donc c'est pour ça que ceux-là jousse
dis pas tiens moi j'ai trois cases
blanches il ya quelques pions 115 noir
qui se dit qu'il a une petite chance que
la de la gagner
techniquement c'est le web les noirs qui
sont mieux dans l'absolu si on va du
joueur chinois pratiquent à l'autre la
raison aucun risque donc là elles sont
très très bien joué un kiki qui fixe son
agacement à fixe
il fixe à
4 euros salut à tous
donc
[Musique]
donc ouais j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup des noirs ici autre âge 5 h 4
et h3 peut-être aussi votre possible
pour fixer des rois ils passent par là
bas j'en sais rien d'autres ajouts au f4
rr d'une robe
comment ça coûte rien de la jouer avec
les noirs non mais en fait pour
améliorer la position je pense que
5h 4h 3 le pion à shockwave à être
menaçant un jour ans parce que si jamais
un jour j'arrive à manger un pion ou
pour ce qu'il est il ya des fois lors un
sacrifice en g3 qui ont presque ouzou
exemple c'est des idées qui peuvent
la couette jj cale je pense qu'il ya
d'ailleurs pas ce que souhaitait la
bienvenue une petite pub pour
plaisir
alors je sais pas si on peut progresser
justement tristan 1 c'est pas que la
france tout cas moi je mettrais un plan
23 après j'essaierai de jouer avec 4
dans les bonnes conditions sont
peut-être mettre un fond en d6 est un
jour férié aux quatre grammy leroy
charef quatre pentes sur souffrance ou
ponction prendre à mes droits à cet
élément g de pignons ici
mais je suis d'accord saga nouvelles
têtes deux nuls mais bon
je crois un moment donné je passe il
maintenant coup d'après toi tu voyais
les planches tout flinguer le chômage
croît il met le front des six a beaucoup
d'autres
c'est vraiment cool club
j'aurais été surpris que je vois des
sept rois servie 3 2003
ça peut être le
messie après environ à une chope à
passer par part en bas à revenir y'a pas
une téléportation quand j'ai passé
pas mal
malheureusement indépendant de notre jeu
face à tours estrémé le streaming
famille parce que bon kamel cette faille
très bien je
suis content quand je fais quand je
propose des coûts qui marche
c'est tellement facile pour l'unique
pas qu'ils n'arrivent pas à créer de
réels problèmes mais on sait jamais hein
encore des moustiques ouais je vais
effectuer là mais pas du d'autres donc
je crois que je 30 cl
enfin maintenant comme aujourd'hui pour
pas qu'ils rentrent
f4 la partie
je veux faire mais
ouais moi je pense que c'est quoi ce
produit en fait ça va être ce qu'il a
raison il ya un les plans qu'on pourrait
avoir plus tard je parle juste d'un
comme matchs 3 et plus tard je
souhaiterais que l'on comparé à en voir
un miroir on sait s'il y aura des
séances à 3 dépotoir des fous h4
comprend la mer je sais bien que
j'attends c'est bien tu arrêtes le frein
à main ou un f2 pour quoi que je puisse
faire un chouette mais c'est l'idée
c'est de trouver des
cas il est parti pour
donc ok mais florence
lepron péter toutes les cases d'ici il
faut aussi j'aimerais
prendre s'il
ya des choses je vois pas du tout
comment tu fais pour essayer sur google
même tu fais un à saint cloud et kapsch
mange en fait
ils ferment ok voilà c'est mieux combler
il a réussi à fermer la position
ok
mais en fait je pense qu'il ya une
raison de la jouer wesley
parce que
ouais puis il a quand même parce qu'elle
lui qui joue pour le gain dans sa
présentation que lui qui peut essayer de
gagner donc la raison de pouvoir de
jouer quand quand il y en a qui va pas
lâcher danube comme ça
dure
mais vu nos petits bleus voilà à bailly
c'est que les voitures toit très long
terme est pas qu aux échecs
[Rires]
chaque qu il y ait d ar
alors perdu 2,4 donc c'est un peu
bizarre ça c'est une ouverture que
j'avais travaillé avec les blancs vous
avez préféré préparer une fois et je
crois que c'est pas terrible pour les
non je crois qu'il ya une partie
notamment de khanaqine avec des blancs
qui avaient
plus ou moins risqué sa vie avec des
systèmes mais voilà des idées mais je me
souviens plus du tout mais un cavalier 5
qui arrive à un moment donné c'est un
plus tout mais c'est bon cette pression
je connais pas du tout jamais vu
ça où trois points très différents
m enfin cette impression qu'il a pas
trop de stratégie mais moi je les trouve
des trucs on va voir
en fait je pense juste que dans les
ouvertures il sait qu'il d'arrière de
toute façon je pense qu'il était un peu
folklo a progressé de 2,5 m sow danse
verticale très solide il est quand même
pas mal de choses enfin
il a plus d'expérience et ouais mais bon
mais là quand on voit les autres qui fut
le début quand même ça ils ne respirent
pas là
les grandes prayssacois et
je pense que juste il essaie de sortir
un peu des trucs priori il envoie ses
pions quoi les poumons ils poussent mais
il ne sort pas ces pièces donc ça j'aime
bien son coût d'un élève deux je pense
qu'il est fou c'est ça qui vous l'a
échangé à couternon après s'installer
sur la carte et steq latour
éventuellement quel stratège bah oui à
temps je pense que c'est ça une fois pas
deux mais on va changer de case noire
ses installations à terre des six donc
c'est que daisy c'est quand même qu'à
une bonne case
pas qu'une bonne case alors du coup l
avant poste
je le dis trouve au centre et
trois pouces et une puissance à devrait
être à zéro oui c'est normal
ah oui là effectivement on voit sur les
scores de chess comme que ils ont gardé
de 5,4 et de 7,2 mais malheureusement
s'agit pas accès j'ai pas accès vraiment
qui touche à ça ces pièces comme ben moi
je relaie l'image qui nous donne et que
eux ils mettent en dia quand tu as même
le score 2001 et 2006 comme qui fait un
sérieux qui le change
et devoirs et donc du coup je peux pas
toucher aussi dur que de dire que vous
prenez pas le nombre de parties dans le
shaq cadence à la vente
on sent qu'il va où leur rouge avec g4
f5 c'est la crosse
qui l'a par hockey aux candidats ont pas
donné son adresse
voient ces choses intéressent pour le
parti on voyait des cadres des trois
pour ses mines alors j'aime pas trop les
noms à réussir
l'adjointe de pied enfin nous faut un
film noir et pourtant tu ne pas écouter
via d'un prêt sur généralement bien on
apprend aux gens de revient on rencontre
les pièges
c'est une perte de temps en fait parce
que du coup lui on voit qu'il va
attaquer la voit donc ses semences aarau
qu'émanant ce côté là bas c'est un peu
que les cimetières mais d'un autre côté
bon mon ressenti c'est pas forcément si
bien que ça
cache 5 lui essayé de bloquer avec gsis
je pense pour
empêcher le contre jeu ici je pense
qu'il va des gc ca voilà
j'aime bien maintenant peut-être qu'un
jour les poires ok parce qu'il aura
moins peur en fait
de l'attak des blancs mais maintenant du
coup avec fougue et 2 les avis là un
jour les fous on se changer et le pion
17 va être un problème toujours les
plans du club bien sûr on est je pense
ça je vous êtes parti a rien de fait un
tiers destin qui peut partir à un moment
donné si ça devait finir
changer les formats ben je sais pas du
tout où le coach est peut-être que ça
n'a pas causé la mort n'a pas fait un
petit moment que kevin ou
des mois alors disons
pas les joueurs en fait les premiers
monsieur regarde quand on allait gagner
même la nuit
[Musique]
tous les premiers à dire que c'est un
format idéal mais les trésors
de faire des petits marathon de trois
heures et demie pour être dire sur la
famille
d'accueil à 15,2
et quand il ya trop d'écart c'est un
cauchemar en fait renaître au départ
parce que je vois les joueurs de galway
quand c'est équilibré c'est intéressant
mais il ya trop d'écarts moi je suis du
match nakamura contre goody fans le
championnat de rugby ont reproduit le
score avec avec avec libye crois que
c'était du du 24 2 je crois comme sa
part que ben oui oui fans c'est
quelqu'un quand même un pape mais on
continue quand il prend 10 0 en 3 plus
franchement
on adore son mandant le changement
points var
les sept qui marche i perdre la
face a fait des matches par excitant
touriste il a fait la str4
ben ouais parce que il est battu web
notamment dans la structure qu'on avait
fait on adore ou qu'on l'avait un joueur
paraguayen le kanak était vraiment
au-dessus de tout le monde moment hyper
forte est en fête avec ceux avec
ce format de 52 cents en fait est bien
le joueur en fait pas rêver la plupart
des matchs et
il a fallu plusieurs 7,1 à pabu encontre
mardi que si la première 1 contre eux
richard mais mais mais mais alors que
sur le score ils avaient peut-être gagné
1,7 genre c'est pas 3 0 et après il
tarde 4 3 par exemple tu vois est en
fait au final ben il doit y avoir genre
7,4 maintenant il ya un an fait et tu
pouvais quand tu es mené au score et ben
tu tu t'es pas encore perdu tu peux
encore te refaire des
tournées de spectateurs c'est ce que
vient de dire à son pendant un bon mois
s'ils veulent garder ce truc il pourrait
faire une heure de plus j'ai pas car il
a même dû l'être après deux à
trois arrêts dont un peu l'endroit sur
la lumière si moi
mais bon il ya des années comme ça donc
peu de chances que ça change
cette position va écouter la russe a
activé sa deuxième tour avec son voile à
venir on sait à peu près équilibré la
tournée s'est établi à cons ces croix
qui composent et là on voit que dans
toutes les finales en fait les noirs
seront mieux généralement parce que les
pions blancs a jusqu'à presque quatre
sont assez le faire au final est par
exemple si on échange par exemple toutes
les pièces qui ont parlé vous et ben du
coup
le fruit noir pourquoi laisser passer
par barrière aller manger des pions
mai
non là je commence clairement à
clairement a préféré maintenant des
bananes trucks et si on ne voit pas
comment tu sors du statu quo avec un
point comme montre la plus obscure de
pions sont obligatoires ces cartes ça me
prend pas exactement où les gardes très
très moche ça permettrait d'avancer
leurs pions ils ont presque voir si
est-ce que éventuellement un comme ça on
pense que tu en france 4 c'est quoi
combler ce manque un peu ambitieux a
plus à y
placer bluff complet mais bah je sais
pas je sais faire des trucs un grand
chelem 3e convention
tour tour d'élite
alors il aurait pu aussi fadam 1,7 avant
ouais mais peut-être qu'il voulait pas
la répétition amusez-vous et vidéo et du
coup j'avais encore une fois le plan est
en
somme une fois que tu défendes qui ont
des buts de 17 ans n'a pas trop loin de
prouver sa dernière demeure d'ailleurs
on commence à le chat room mois à mais
je l'avais d enlever le toit ce qu'ils
ont
je vais m'occuper parce que quand
j'avais fait
moi je peux le faire aussi mais je le
fais en fait
alors c'est vrai que là ils l'ont
normalement c'est bon parce que ça
l'était à jouer
ok donc ça c'est intéressant ça bouge un
petit peu du coin tu prends des 7 je
prends ces trois
jeux
complètement complètement
donc du coup ça eminem a parlé
dans ce camp qui les conforte sa
position il fait des petits il sera que
la gorge on voit de sa connexion est pas
terrible il a une seule barre attention
saut raté ce très beau ça pourrait
utiliser des masses au cachot sur la
chaise
au retour qu'on 17 uréthane cellule
peut-être
même suis tourné 3 et bécasses et quatre
non ça marchera pas ça on apprend que
j'avais 4 1 pas du tout parce qu'ils
auraient c4 qui stabiliserait la
position
en voix g 16
il ya quand même pas mal attention sur
le roi qu'un peu faible comme justement
v6
rentrer un peu là-bas le pirate qui
pourraient être faibles un jour en un
jour d'amin
d'investissement normalisés
comme t6 donc là échanges et bien sûr
qu'on refuse le temps d'être au tour 6 1
qui paraît autour des 5 et en fait ça
pour rien parce que ça vous arrive
si je vends quelque part j'ai dû dames
invitées des échecs et des pions tu peux
manger après sa capitale la vie de la
mère
la tension autour des outils peut
arriver au sénat il l'a aidé à prendre
mais attention ça pourrait faire mal
évidemment les fuites le site sur un
malentendu
sauf si on peut annuler un ce que tu
accuses de la nul et je pense qu'il
prend des risques un
arsenal et si sa part exercice dans mes
filles seront h7 tour des huit encore
tombés
mais il faut jouer à wow cette force et
un petit perpétuelle
attention attention
ça peut pour sa famille je pense qu'il
va le sud par tout
d'abord comme qui reste le tragique ok
la scène grunge grecque
j'entends le
déni pause
il a redit qu'il y ait yannick pays
continue à jouer seront compatibles je
pense que les gens ne se rendent pas
mieux du coup les gars c'est la pause on
va revenir dans je crois que c'était
huit minutes ce matin macro qui était
annoncé c'est beaucoup ouais mais bon on
verra un tout petit peu avant comme
d'hab et donc votre un petit pub de tous
comme donc c'est pas la pub normal de
tweets charles a sévèrement pièces comme
est donc avant tout de suite
[Musique]
à
nous sommes de retour des amis les
joueurs vont s'installer devant si vous
aussi ça arrive est prêt
a plus que ceux qui qui
qui arrivent vont devoir on doit arriver
là sur la caméra ok
moi je l'entends via leur via le zoom de
tendance
la rocqué pour l'instant fait sa rivale
à un peu moins
vif que contre rapport rien dans
l'attitude et la ramsi pandora mouche
pour petits meurent c'est une
je
pense que s'il est dans l'aude
je crois qu'il ya 90 décalage avec avec
celle ayant tout alors j'ai pas trop
vite et que je crois qu'il est chez
naïve
il ya 88 décalage avec la france où la
sueur au même aux meilleurs que nous
bourse aux maîtres l'après midi au caire
il s'agit bien comme chez moi
ce que si vous les gars 23 heures je
pense que c'était bien lui et moi
regarder g20 comme ça va être un projet
minière
j'espère que dans quelques heures
j'espère que tu
ne veux pas te voir arriver à venir mais
je pense que c'est que je pense que je
peux je m'engage
parce que moi je pense que c'est vers 8
heures que je savais comment ça se passe
chez
donc dans une bouteille
parti à lille a encore changé de
style ouais c'est ca l'espagnol dont il
ya un gros débat théorique entre entre
caruana esso le rat match d'areva fois
de ce type là et du coup ça arrive je
travaillais là il a clairement eu match
fut dix matches et je pense filiale de
faire taire quelques préparations sur
les espagnols qui l'ont vue donc
voilà
je suis en argentine emmanuel rien
en ce moment je suis en voyage
ma 14e cannage ça va je parle juste
avant la pause et la minimisation
intéressante jarawa informatique en
nuage pour
quelqu'un qui nous devons user coach ce
n'est d'ailleurs pas seul si d'après toi
ce genre de tournoi on a vu de plus en
plus sur internet depuis proville est ce
que ça vaut s band si la colline où le
voulez mais pas ternir amis
la diminuer ou disparaît et un jour tu
penses que la hype du chèque son
internet du tournoi sur l'internet ont
perduré au delà
ben moi je pense que ça va perdurer en
tout cas parce que c est très facile de
faire un tournoi avec des joueurs du top
mondial sans se déplacer et
mais bon et la gratte on a trié jeu
toujours celle là nous pour les
meilleurs aujourd'hui il faut et puis
ses parents elle officie elle l'abordé
en des temps puisqu'il ya des les prix à
chaque coin sont
parfois des centaines de milliers
d'euros
mais mais oui donc ça c'est un problème
clairement c'est un problème qu'on va
vraiment faire face toujours retrouver
un moyen de permettre à merville chez
les joueurs
donc c'est un peu compliqué aussi les
miens après je pense que
on pense à continuer parce que tout ce
qu'aime une facilité quand même pour les
sponsors pour des tournois pour
l'organisation est en vente mais après
c'est vrai que ça remplacera jamais les
paiements potentiels et d'ailleurs quand
on voit tout le temps moi qui ai
organisé pendant que pendant leur
confinement pour au début mais moi
j'étais content quand on est tous
c'était assez cool et où vous voyez
carlingue de tous les jours mais plus ça
dure et plus je trouvais que c'était
chiant
une over
j'aurais même pu la franche même pu
gagner quoi bien je pense que même les
joueurs ils s'en foutent les sna
bellemare dit voilà je veux arriverait
mais là bah ouais t'es là on t'offre
l'argent comme ça fait une partie ils
vont faire baril d'ailleurs il ya même
beaucoup polémique à mon équipe a
souffert d'un traumatisme une période
généralement le nul de sa roue mais la
belle nul tout temps d'apprendre et 4 et
à ne pas nous faire
sur l'espagne la rage est alors
parti gilles beck
c'est ce qu'il dit et resto je crois
qu'il va dire fuck quelque chose on
a pas de
médailles l'état cherche pas et est sans
rapport avec sa connexion internet
là il a une barre le sida
robinette
mais alors que contre famille il était
hyper des niveaux
des connexions je sais pas peut-être que
quelqu'un est passé par là avec un
sécateur
fait les fils chez pas et ça pour être
instituée sur cette demi-finale même
temps ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas eu
de femme nue connexion dos et ça
m'arrange hautement encore sur sarine
maroc accueille comme ça une blague le
tournoi toutes ces machines et gagne il
a quand même pas dessus il a quand même
battu donc c'est tellement rapport sans
connexion now km et contre rapport et un
quinté + 9 1 h 19
cavalia du coup il conclu
les prestations elle a perdu il ya une
paire de souillac un t5 avec un piano
dans des 4 donc ça as quand même
résignation
on a mangé la manche mais je ne suis pas
fan du tout
d'être mangé la est amené à vivre manger
la vague
est en feu de moldavie khor
abéché que d'apprendre à présent lors du
dernier sondage mais non monsieur
rupture d'un proche de zéro auquel et b6
des points la tour cellou a
l'egypte détail les bonzes du coup les
revenues cordiale s'avère bien pour les
vendre ouais vous propose du pion je
pense parce que
jusqu'au 25 avril indélogeable mais au
moins un magasin régime c'est
mais depuis n'est pas isolé
mais projet fou de 3,31 êtres en plus
des structures
je pense faire
aurait mangé le même temps j'adore jeu
qu'avec des cinq quand même
atari volet justice et 6ème et je veux
l'être un fourré ça quand
aucun talent à 107 emplois le plan
d'éclat tu mais ils font ici la dame
lights à ces contrôles bien ils
attaquent défaut et ils bloquent la
colonne de
total et l'existence pour ces actifs
c'était l'idée intéressante
est-ce qu'on peut déranger là bas je ne
suis pas sûr que je vous demande et
bella vous sentez le diable ça va un peu
trop gris 10 1 sur l'échelle trois là
d'un point à 7 pour g6 et du cas dsk qui
peut arriver
ça l'art quand même toi là-bas mais les
particuliers une
une fraise la barbarie c'est maintenant
je prenais loire
c'est un outil calculs
30 ans a vendu la
peau qui passe un truc avec sa tour
aussi les jeux avec une tour de mon
nom c'est très très durable il a fait
échec pour rien par compteur s'était
beaucoup de l'ordinateur c'est pas bien
compris pourquoi encore mais
budget soit meilleur affichage 3 donc il
veut le seul là mais ok c'est pas
évident de trouver sa mort il a bien
vieilli en caves
ses abonnés alsace quelque chose ou pas
il n'a pas pu venir al
massae l'aja perd avec les blancs et les
noirs je te j'annonce
la paire surtout avec les blu ray petter
en écriture aussi
par la taille du souffle à lastours
projet 3 annonce lors de la rave set
pour prendre les trois étrangers 3 dans
le problème de la belgique de ma part
d'un problème de la perte nette
atteint 20,3 l'abus seconde à la
banqueroute de minutes
3 c'est
le niveau taille jeu compliqué parce
qu'il a eus sont attendus s'il parle pas
ça fait un vrai quand ça fait deux
points d'avancé plage pour sow il peut
forcer la nulle du coup
une
proposition d'échangé de l'émotion prend
à croire surtout avatar
jusqu'à la finale avec de bonnes pour le
bourg on suit la faire tout on les prend
au mieux
pas rester pragmatique
qui des trois
c'est le court peut-être regarder les
tables
brembilla lui avec 33 qui perd là aussi
on
prendrait
[Musique]
un jour
les fameux 4 il fut notamment le cas des
neuf
cases blanches mais là et chaque échec
n'importe quoi la glace et les cages
attention que l'on croit qu'il fallait
aussi un
il croit dans le iv en fait on donc
échec tu reviens là pour empêcher d'agir
c'est plus précis cet amas de terre met
à me 4 à chaque fois donc c'était un peu
précis mais bon moi il a joint pouvoir
6,30 mickey pour sa reste vrais pour la
c1 fondatrice propice aux
4 h
264 voilà il ya trouvé un four châtain
ça soit des années de froid qui peut
revenir au bureau ça non mais là il
prend quelques risques c'est
l'impression
auxquelles nul
bon
ok donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
pour pour sarine qui a réussi à défendre
cette feria à ton avis qu'il a checké
sont allés keane pendant la pause bye
bye la gc 6 tu vois déjà avant de
décider ok pourquoi vers la semaine 4 ça
c'est normal et sûr ça et que 17 kg
c'est que sur les bords du cp1 km ft
atteint
cavaillé 26 ou en bep
607 dos il possède en tout cas pas des
pros vous dire sur six ans et ses
thématiques au sur ses positions
donc je n'accepte fouet tout 4km
étrangement
11 ans en raison d'un genou rang des
trous qu'il ya pas de
la région spéciale
ou trois rocs cavale et c3 il va y avoir
quelle vague 17 j'imagine et surtout
comme cavalli et celles d'armand le
pousser cavale depuis trois ans on
recule pour garder le centre s'est pas
joué cette carte est ce qu'un seul
changement possible possible peut-être
le coup d'ailleurs monsieur climatique
en fait de reculer comme ça c'est
thématiques pour garder des pièces en
fait alors c'est ça que j'aime beaucoup
ils veulent casser
pour casser les centres villes c'est pas
mal
là on voit que les blancs qu'un homme
bon un bel avantage de centre avec les
pièces de au centre et les pions c4 donc
et
ça se sent
ça ainsi ma excès noircissent plus
faible
attention qui va surtout ça qui peut
être en prison si je bouge montre par
exemple puis avant un ton compte en
consultant un set
c'est vrai essayer de mettre en c3 3
août au point de penser 3 suivi de
calqué sur apple après c'est l'autre en
c3 c'est un coût qui est toujours
jouable pour casser la sueur des pions
cassin place nos pions mais les gars se
voir sur les treize donc c'est un coup
vraiment tout autre en change maintenant
je voudrais jouer plein de manières
j'en changerai pas de quoi
en faire
why not
5 ce qui inquiète son plan ce que je
fous ces deux c'est de gagner la colère
d'un boss
software trois ans les gens seraient
d'accord avec détroit a calculé manger
là tu manges là du coup je m'entoure en
large comment john à sa calculé faut
voir mais je pense que l'idée c'est
clairement dit que je fous ces deux
hommes on sort une pièce en temps quand
on craint qu'on prend un sérieux coup
c'est un donc eh bah il s'en est bien
sorti avec les noirs
il va défendre son point c'est tout on
essayait de quoi
la question c'est est ce que rend le
tout étant prises contre 42,6 tâche que
je vous prends un set et là tous les
docteurs c'était genre de tour à 8 avec
vous prendre en c3
après moi j'aime bien parce que ça oui
pas de ces une défense active
c'est mieux de jouer activement comme ça
que de 2 juin comme à 6 ou à 5 ou encore
pirate ou rallye se sait jamais possible
comme ça pas passé comme ça
mais il faut jouer actif dans
l'opposition dès qu'on peut
engager 4 1 une fouille par été tués le
4 pour le roi donc sa gamme ultime jour
de position au passage il ya une case
encore en d3 pour mon fou et c'est le
coup derrière mais faire attention que
se couvraient plus être perdus dans les
précédents
ok
peut-être maintenant qui n'a pas joué à
6 chez bar sur aube
paraît judicieux
bon en fait c'est pas bien le jeu et
passifs s'en arrange en l'avenir mais
des fois il ya des moments où il faut
qu'un coup défendre l'option
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en
monnaies il faut défendre des pions
décoiffe à 6 mg et on échange mais faut
des retours à vide ou à d'autres pour
allez pas vous ah oui non comme tours à
huit ça serait vraiment
vraiment l'aboutissement quoi ranger au
sénat c'est interdit ça ses interviews
dont 17 pourquoi pas la limite est
clouée dans les deux c'est pas débile ça
j'aimerais ça a
expliqué les can fly va essayer d'être
chaud 2,5 alors j'aime pas trop c'est
simple je voudrais la caste et 5 mai le
synchro vais peut-être
km de l'étape derrière ses multiples
initiatives accord alors cette partie il
prend un peu fatigué de la répéter les
coups ça mais il est mené au score mais
je pense que là où il a plus de chance
de gagner un sign c'est qu'on a quand
même s'accélère il ya deux heures
non ok mais je vais au lit en fait c'est
que essayer de de perdre avec un score
on va dire
peut-être serré possible en simple plus
une pour après c'est prendre le dessus
dans les cadences plus rapide oui après
vous à jouer les positions
non moment bien sûr il est vrai que dans
l'esprit vers la position morale
conséquente au terme d'une année noire
allait nulle
répétitions
auxquelles elle cédera mettre la
pression et les plans pour égaliser
un petit système de londres cotait tenu
de l'enjeu
je les ai vu qu il aille bien une partie
comme ça contre le grand maître des
émirats la salam salam fayyad et il ya
eu à dubaï et hagard et retrait il ya
quelques jours là et j'ai vu une vidéo
il a une partie comme ça il ya une
structure mais cet été
donc la gagner mais un
wes 15 bon en fait il a fait exploser le
donner un appui en fait elle s'avérait
que
ce n'est pas le nom enfin je pense un
but de la partie est du coup je pense ça
arrive ce n'est bien c'est cette piste m
de long et qui est pas malheureux dans
ses positions donc on va voir un peu ce
thème donc j'ai 300 pêche un peu le but
de cavani et 400 m haies avec le front
en g2 mais j'ai l'intention à foix à 6
aussi un qui peut poser problème sur le
roc est
fou de dôngs à
l'affiché trois recours du coup prend la
carte du cavalier alors petit rock et un
jour tout neuf cadres à changer les
pièces je compte changer de case moi on
va voir mais qu à mes trousses en cases
noircies de lumière puisque le fou de 6
ça peut manger des vers 2h 4h stocks je
pense que c'est clairement aux sidéens
ouais mais on en retenir
ouais mais je vois que le ranger 2 qui
fait h 14 h et je crois que ça va
du coup il ya beaucoup de malades
est-ce qu'il faut être quatre à jouer tu
peux je veux cinq je pense qu ils ont
calculé et on va laisser les joueurs là
[Rires]
bas dès que je pense que le foot roi est
perdu enfin il va être échangé n'est pas
défendable
donc
ouais je suis pas très dispendieux
les proches des deux soli la faune
deuxième j'avais mon style de musique
ouais je vais passer devant moi
je
pense que tous les styles
surtout qu'en plus elle et elle dit ça
mais si tu suivais mestric je vois
qu'elle tenait régulièrement
du coup je crois qu'on va l'inviter sur
le strip quel calcul pour nous je pense
qu on va partir de ça parce que nous a
franchement l'aveu de 1300 elle ou en
chambre en match de poule alors que je
jamais tu vas aimer et maintenant je
crois que chef de
[Rires]
1500 femmes de 2100 en date est un
problème
et c'est pas fini mon client et c'est
pas chinois voient les deux joueurs ils
n'ont pas voulu non plus rentrer
là-dedans opinion aussi voyons peut-être
calculé dans leur tête mais
ils vont l'apprendre
4 à partir
c'est un peu anti positionnelle mais bon
ça s'empêche 5
je suis plus aussi du suspect courage 3
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant sur les quatre ans et plus
et des coûts qui me vient à l'esprit
mais après comment progresse n'apparaît
pas appeler
ça un peu bloquée
c'est que ça que sur ses bancs de la
fraîcheur de chercher des
gens voient même pas le premier noir
parce que comme simple sera va me poser
du temple de 50 à
tort dans les contrées voilà
dans la cave à 9,5
des bulles et le lot baisse à 30 ans à
tartas et les 2300 n'ont pas même pas
d'en bas je pensais qu'avec ta victoire
bannon probable tel t1 combien je sais
même pas comment je devais même pas
grave mais je dois être à 80 85 et
jendouba si je pensais qu'ils étaient
descendus genre à 90 séquelles qui n'ont
elles sont descendues à
c'est un peu comme un cheveu sur
j'ai fait un tournoi au maroc tim c'est
à 80
travail pelouse j'ai parlé des points je
suis content j'avais
j'ai perdu des points ce tournoi
je n'ai pas perdu beaucoup joué pendant
quatre cinq ou six
classes à chaud très chaud ce soit
en feed
j'étais à 23 90 1 6 point de placer m lg
leur jeu une centaine de points et du
coulage effet région en équipement j'ai
28 ans m
on va mettre un petit mètre
bientôt elle a bien du coup
bas étaient ils étaient amis il avait 22
80 mais il avait 60 ans donc j'étais un
mec blanc que chatel à paris pourquoi
pas a priori non parce que le mec tout
notre effectif vers fort il est
hyperactif jeu comme tourneur et dans
trauma d'être nul à 20,6
bon bah machin je fais chaque parti mais
qu'il a produit deux fois nul de la fin
il m'a dit qu'il était nul jeudi par
nicolas
la finale j'ai deux tours contre les
algues et moi qui veut gagner des badges
ou quoi
mais bon typique soit ouverte
crédibilité plus en plus de toit sont
donc les en ligne
il croit près qu'il tarde trop ce que je
comprends très bien c'est c'est un peu
le penalty en ce moment
c'est clair je viens c'est penalty quand
ils comptent toutes façons tu t'es à
s'il gagne pas contre c'était un
problème quoi tu as mal cadrées ou c'est
que je sais pas
[Musique]
bref pas grand chose dans ce parti un
nom sai baba appel à certaines parties
du championnat du monde
lors des deux premières rondes
bon après d'envoi quelques sorts ont
l'impression qu'ils donnent l'impulsion
des cinq
d'améliorer la plus austère qui n'arrive
pas à passer son tour cette fois que
les plans pour le couvrir mais les noirs
pour ensemble noir améliore qu'il que tu
peux en tirer cinq arrivées 5 à 5 y voir
un peu ce qui se passait après ses
quinze ans mais cissé g25 peut-être
montre comme ça je sais pas
alors deux tours sera enfin je pourrais
de tour m'a tellement j'ai joué cinq
fois
en règle générale de tours ça dépend la
policia
9.10 et bien sûr l'échec ce qu'on s'est
dit
certaine que ça dépend des pollutions
moi c'est une finale où j'avais capture
on avait quatre pions chacun et et de
tours contre une dame en fait moi mon
plan c'est de doubler mes tours sur un
pion d'aller manger le pion et quand lui
sarif la dame sur les tours va à la fin
j'ai
donc le square et techniquement c'était
gagne en importance j'ai bien joué la
dame en fait elle avait
bien c'est la dose qui avec alger oran
cavaliers pour les déménagements et
c'est vraiment tout seul de toute chose
un pressoir du perpétuel 4010 maurouard
audimut m ça va dépendre de bas
je pense que la
de la position qu'on m'a dit que ça leur
met derrière dans la généralement les
tours sont meilleures
en fait on a une illustration à gauche
pas d'humour justement la fameuse partie
scories de la plus longue de l'histoire
du quaduro du 40e ra gagné la partie 6
bat pour cavaliers c'était deux tours
dans des bases soude temps conseil d'arr
carson avait les deux tours parce qu'il
va partir bien sûr prévu l'apartheid et
mais diable de bonheur
finalement et les deux tons il
abandonnera il abandonnerait sa propre
aux ex course réveiller
le dragon boat show man comme ça est
très rare et enjeux du tour contre une
dame à très haut niveau c'est rare je
crois que
[Musique]
c'est arrivé j'ai pas arrivé depuis
donc la gamme so qui a réussi à bien
mauvaise position est revenue à la
parole cinq ans qu'on nous trompe que
sarine il n'y a rien qui l'attendaient
les marchés phares et la position il a
défendu lecture dessin qu'il a tous
poussé et la main à l'iran
mais encore une fois tu vois le temps
sarine qui parce qu'il fait il dort dans
ce match il a tout le temps il met de
l'eau tard et
et c'est compliqué
les lada cinq lapins de choix
et oui c'était bizarre parce qu'en tous
rêvent de deux gains et pau quelle
époque j'ai de force et cette mission à
wimbledon le pion à son concurrent la
non bah oui c'est bien sûr un prêt mais
je veux dire de base déjà le tour pour
sylvie je crois les deux tours pour
avoir
le droit chemin
après s'être rangée de le pousser ces
scanners de ça ça ça marche tant
que lors de coups le deux menaces a
peut-être qu'il ya mille procès 5 et 2
kg
mais pourquoi fait il ya d'un projet
mais c'est pareil que ce parc créé sur
le deuil allait prendre la france à 9,5
dommage puisque eux de regarder bien si
jamais il n'est pas qu'elle prendrait 5
1 3 à 5 ans prend la salle était bien
parce que à la fin on a
bien joué la gagne ça doit gagner on
sent que la gagner pour les eaux qui
laisse la tour en prison break pour
chacune clément de tours
et donc ça fait 5 3 il reste un quart
d'heure dans des matches où tu raques
ans encore deux parties mais la gagner
avec les noirs alors opposition a priori
mais
voilà beaucoup mieux compris la position
en fait sauf qu'encore une fois c'est le
genre qui qui joue vite qui est solide
et qui contre bien et les joueurs ont
envie qu'ils se soient impressionnés tu
as et c'est vraiment la fin y vivent
complet dans sa mère veut jouer
[Musique]
je crois f5 comportement privé puis on
prend avec probablement d'un mach 4 et
un problème sur f2 qui arrivait donc ça
joue très vite la cave l'ergonomie ici
quand on peut peut-être espérer un
tas mais l'usta l'heure pas très bon on
vous prend pour franck et des cinq
attaques la tour 4 à 6 et 7 10 des 600
vraiment dessin sentir les pièces
qu'elle valait premier fils je prends en
c4
non pas du tout comme ça ok
je sens que farine décision sa prépa
on jubile un rythme mois juste
mission moi j'ai pas en fait à chaque
ouverture et d'allumer un truc différent
des comics à tâtons pile dans un truc
qu'il advienne progrès
dans les fils d'amis ici on trouve des
positions qu'on avait jamais eu de temps
de jeu attention à ce qui me concerne
quand la pièce est un péage sans qu'ils
préparaient d'avoir une position petite
indienne avec une attaque assez forte
j'aurai avec l'âge 5 les tours sur l'âge
changé je garde juste à
partir en chasse à
l'oeuf ou la poule g 4 ou un v6 et la
tour f 4 doit pouvoir être rejoué en
jetant allait très bien qu'ils aillent à
grasse elle n'ira pas avec les acteurs
noirs adaptateurs belkin
boccolacci petit bras moi j'ai malka
devons jouer le tour en f4 ou ça casse
et la connexion data imagix des jeunes -
ouais
là près du cou et sa case f4 le cul par
un cavalier donc peu trash s'ils se
stabilisent et après de faire une
interview avec quatre de plus malin que
nous
attentions avec et vis-à-vis de la tête
du sous les toits je pense qu il va de
l'orangé 2 c'est pour ça qu'il avait
trois je pense qu'il me semblait
l'espace du toit qui est un problème est
maintenant voir si afin de sacrifices
je peux en fait les arrivages sont ils
vont faire mal mais
pour l'instant le flou contrôle ici mais
ne pas laisser la place
à nicolas pas pris je viens
julien
g départ arrêtera commentaires solal
des hommes 327
[Rires]
paraissent
alors non qu'est tour d'être docteur
froid y était du g4 des fois tu sais
couper la connexion dont on comprend 3 3
mais la girafe ou prend pour l'instant
ça a l'air de marcher tous à se trouver
les vidéos qui est réussie c'est normal
tu me laisses place
de place
est-ce que vous avez laissé tomber
l'idée d'un rêve cette fête
pour
créer une vraie menace sur un an plus
tard tu me l'as tourcoing 3 une fois que
tu as dame henri vii où il joue
il est complètement coût
anticipé et sort
alors là je dis oui oui oui
c'est intéressant ce qu'il fait en ce
campus ou la sage 5 et
ses larmes et anouar ben moi
c'est très chaud je dois trouver un sens
ira toujours ça donc c'est l'arrière
droit
connecteront cela
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les blancs là
c'est compliqué je vois que l'ordinateur
est dit qu'il faut des progrès m
cammalleri 413 sur l'absinthe peut-être
un peu les idées
et surtout trois fois donc il
y avait une défense comme ça échec
hyper choqué les inquiète pas très
humain en vain à
la
mi-temps mais trouve tous les coups bas
c'est juste fou
et la d7 la 6-3
4-6 peu le h4 derrière ça va commencer à
faire mal parce que hk après peut-être
un petit gf3 pour prendre toutes les
cases
jordan lui même dans les choses qu'il a
raison parce que h4 faut pas nous
permettre à ces enfants un chat
j'espère que ça va craquer alinéa l'état
n'ira
comment gérer que les noirs
ce qui ira la
pénalité
pense pas qu'il héritait
il a joué je prends h4 il à faire il a
fait dans un grand soupir de l'herbe
comme ça
dommage lorsqu'on l'a plaqué déjà fait
la semaine dernière via même pas arrivé
on va quand même pas laisser où elle est
arrivée à 6 kw à 1,6 point qua
non
s'il arrive à 6 points ça fait se situe
voies et
espaces à paris j'avais déjà fait donc
du coup c'est l'époque j'ai là c'est un
petit peu redondant tu vois quand
qu'autour d'eux mêmes blagues enfin même
si quand on n'a pas d'autre va c'est un
peu compliqué je démarre
comme un chat il ya un petit cheveu sur
la langue
il va tuer repousser toute
charge sais pas comment je représente 6
à la demande et au
f4
c'est très très jeunes partent en tout
cas
ses choix pour l'asca t'choupi news
a fait un bide j'ai pas compris ça
secoue la nuit
je ne voudrais pas sûr
c'est toujours pas compris y'a pas ton
projet quatre
balises d'un moment et j'apprécie
mais attention à chaque
été des échecs avec les voir mais il
doit espérer un retour à genoux devant
mes gardes j attends ça ça ça se mange
pas ça ça sympa que ce cheval
est mort il faut un échec non parce que
je vais te mèneront un jour
oui je te dise à la hâte que ça c'est à
st
et ça jusqu'à +1 ok il battre tous
ensemble être la dame contre le kamikaze
de blanc chance importante il fallait au
jeune héros aussi le cavalier votre
barque devant un miroir meilleure
défense à
la juste avant un cavalier côte à côte
en fait et vous êtes attaqués par une
dame trouvée il est super de royer s'ils
vont de 15 des échecs est tous
assez fort puisqu'ils font marie grech
et du coup ici ça a l'air de lumière il
a super bien calculé l'hôpital l'embargo
s'il craque pas et devrait revenir à 5 4
c'est cool pour l'intérêt du match le
fou défend f2 ce si important parce
qu'il ya eu pire artois des échecs et
les points f2 ces
dames 6 après ça on voit les joueurs ils
vont pas faire trop ou réfléchir à un
recours ils réfléchissent à une chute de
5,6 vous la jouez pas et a pris aux
réfugiés
dans ces eaux noires de le faire dès
michel de s'amuser
alors comment on
s'est échangé les tables par exemple
si on peut ce serait bien de le faire
mais je vois pas comment un père t'a
toujours ça mais c'est malheureux mais
bon au moins grâce à des fuites by le
joug ouvrant au moins que on perd pas
déjà c'est quand même marjan kalhor
projet n'était pas possible parce que le
cavaliere cette même si le cloud et
contrôler la case vous pourriez prendre
avec la table non mais faut il pas
d'être g8 avoir beaucoup d'avant avant
la belle fille dati veut je fous là et
essayer de vous pouvez être amené la
dame en f2 ouais ben son rendez vite
pour se déclarer voilà essayé de la
jouer si d'ici
là maintenant ça il a dû voir la vitesse
à laquelle il a joui koulaguine à tour
par la tchèque comme ça
je suis roi ici je dois avoir mandat
loger deux
là doivent attendre un trou avec
ok tout homme machin je pense
bête et moi je prendrai pour exemple
à lunettes jaunes matin avant bon
bah c'est cool ça te laisse en 4 5 4 et
il va 5 minutes au compteur pour la
portion de 5 plus simple donc du coup
s'il pouvait gagner celle-là et faire
5-5 entre empêcher ce serait parfait
pour moi j'ai comme celle
de l'aller s'amuse à faire dispatcher
mettez du cousseau assez largement
travaux même genre en toute précision de
et on apprend par exemple que geralt
staline est beaucoup plus fort les
mardis généralement il ya plus de partir
de mardi
l'histoire est pleine
j'espère que tu vas devenir très fort à
partir de 00h01
ce marocain
mais en fait vous sortir un nouvel outil
pour gary c'est rigolo
je crois être montrée miom sur des
points
tout est stable mais vraiment c'est un
truc ultra complète avec des stats du
coup bas
pour trois mois nous en tous genres quel
jour de la semaine vous avez parti akel
n'a
pas tout
avoir quant à toronto de pré saison
lorsque ce parti est cependant possible
à semarang tout un tas de trucs sur
quelle ouverture d'habitués le plus mal
accueilli par
mes
services pour les gens qui vont essayer
de voir s'il n'obtient qu'il est gratuit
souligné on admire au disco
sortie laxisme en 2001
socke est pas content
pour charger non mais dès qu'il fait un
petit bruit crois que c'est game amour
je l'écris dans le chat
comme
gratuits sont à l'abonnement je crois
que c'est ça je crois
dans
magdalena
avons traduit ça j'ai l'impression par
perspective
samarraï aucun sens
j'aurais pas trop
les bleus là où on allait le sont les
articles
chez les coen que j'aime bien il veut je
souffrais 3 je pense il avait le 4 mai
secousse est pas fou à 5 contre
3 pour échanger lecavalier et ensuite
remettre l'équipe sur cette route
étroite maintenant on a une position
avec des pions qui sont pendants donc
c'est le point qui sont assez poireau
semble mais qui va être faible
attention aussi aux vis-à-vis entre les
haïtiens c'est compliqué
alors merci pour le lien pour le chat ce
qui va jeter un oeil
sur sur vos stats apparent
gratis vous avez l'abonnement moi je
voyais pas ne tient pas réagi pour
trancher
mais je suis pas sûr mais pas les
abonnements et c'est possible qu'il a
débuté comme tout ça ça a évolué que
genre dans deux mois
mais comme en irak ou au chaos où les
leviers
et du coup là dans l'article et
chaque check your insight dans la soirée
à 4/4 sélective que des traducteurs
différents états
bref vous avez le lien
il faut être
vraiment c'est le diamant c'est le 2 mai
le plus grand événement c'est
l'abonnement max
c'est peut-être un peu dérapé parce que
ça vient de sortir pinard allemand mais
après ils vont se rendre compte que
personne ne le fait l'homme est gratuit
mais c'est de gagner un abonnement
diamant tous les jeudis soirs et une
arène francophones à 20h30 d'allemand et
à
35 hongrois
j'ai vu que c'est un forum internet -
tout le monde tout à gagner au niveau
atteint fin 2005 sans que j'aie vraiment
accessible il
est chaud au coeur d'un bon ben moi tous
les jeux qui seront en vente à
faire partie du club français sur chaise
comme pour le coup elle s'égare à tuer
toute égalité
alors passage cette phase est celle
de la question
faisait docteur on
fait défiler un peu le truc donc bon que
j'aimais pourcentage de cas l'un d'eux
qui pourra qu une couleur une précision
des couleurs c'est l'adversaire
par rapport aussi beaucoup dans une
cache une partie vont à partir longtemps
et mettre des affiches en
ville selon les différentes face des
poteaux pression finale au milieu de
maisons voitures par rapport à toutes
les tactiques qui peut voir exactement
le nombre de fourchette que tu as
tu pas rater les verts on fait pas mal
aussi c'est que par rapport à ta tronche
et louis de 10 cycles rap vous voit plus
par exemple des fonctions que les gens
vous approchez vous pareil c'est une
tactique
apparemment etc je vais te voir dans
quels domaines beauce et du coup c'était
bon impact et the white a des bons
résultats contre bas par exemple les
indiens particulièrement
fou qu'on l'a caressé a l'air pas mal au
point d'ailleurs barreaux
moi j'aurais fait tomber sa plainte elle
aura du coup la barthe ça dit quoi
alors didonne d'amd c'est que j'avais
pas comprendre pourquoi
je comprends pas pourquoi il veut
absolument les ici à boucler cette
attaque le fou pourra tomber cet emploi
j'ai pensé pour ta cavale l'ex avocat
prêt mais en fait il dit je
crois avoir compris c'est que sur ça il
peut mettre le fou par la fota m17 je
peux pas accepter qu aux deux dames
c'est ce que chaque bateau sur tournage
aurait imposé cette fois les deux tours
mais bon c'est quand je regarde il est
vraiment celle ci fait d'amener cette
chapelle l'appel l'arbitré
ouais il peut y trouver qui a décidé
quoi
c'est vrai que du club entre les
rejoindra ya vraiment un acteur vous
rejoignez après tous les jeudis le lien
du tournoi vous aimez pour le club
facilement vous inscrire ben ça bout de
mur avancer tous les jeudis à 20h30 à
21h30 c'est du trois plus gros
oui clairement les clairement les les
thomas arena sur comme ça c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout le monde et tout le monde
peut gagner aurait atteint pas parce que
tu es plus fort j'aurais dû gagner que
généralement t elle à paris les gens de
ton niveau adéquat donc ça veut dire que
même s'il était forte les courants les
plus forts en fait donc c'est pas dit
que tu gagnes tout est
quand un miel auparavant comme des
milliers modèle des chances ouais c'est
intéressant de ce point
petite fourchette et je crois que tu es
perdu samedi là bravo on ira la sarine
qui va qui veut attirer devait cette
partie ce qui fera du coup 5,5 dans
cette portion de blitz qui est pas mal
du tout pour lui un du coup parce que je
pense que c'est là où tu es normalement
le moins
[Musique]
sur le papier oui mais attention quand
même à ça
peut-être qu'à valider cinq madame seitz
alors pas mal
je crois aussi aussi peuvent être
correct
à baba kaké points
il ya une pause de six minutes qui vient
de les définir ouais on termine et donc
du coup on va passer en trois minutes
pour la pour la suite et
et on vous dira tout de
ses 27 passes que les noirs tout ça j'ai
lu ça me regarde
mes lives et en fait c'était sûr ça
on avait vu que sur ça y avait sa
voiture tombée beach et pousse cette
attaque les deux tours
à minimiser mais je pense qu'il y avait
ici en fait fou ses huit matches le fou
sur cette diagonale là mais là j'étais
m6 mon attaque la tour est en chute
faisait cette
voie là je t'aime il arrivait beaucoup
c'est ce que j'avais vu et sur fois
c'est la refonte et ben j'ai encore une
fois une époque double ici alors que son
retour 17 à la place il y avait tous ces
huit et là malheureusement pas je peux
pas acheter quoi faire ça d'ailleurs
mais avant ça ça énerve à tour emprise
donc peut-être que ça c'est pas possible
les pièces des noirs sont évidemment
ouais donc je joue la vague du coup
voilà en fait
mesdames 17 en fait c'était fort parce
qu'ils font il ya l'idée d'en fermer le
fabriquer tour soit connecté
écoutez on va l'en pause on vous vous
redis adam maintenant 3 4 minutes a plus
la pièce a tout de suite
[Musique]
les stars telegraph minutes aller on est
revenus en reste lui qui nous tombe
dessus donc là il demande à ceux de
mettre la lumière chez lui parce que
je crois qu'il n'entend pas
quand ça fait un peu la star au noir ont
viré un peu le voile
ok ça l'est
on voit le prix miles island sarine
l'homme de l'ombre c'est cela
on peut stif et l'unef fait vachement
qui a des lunettes basso
ces mafieux corps
vous voyez partie
et on va reprendre du coup donc cinq
sacs pleins portion de 5 2 semaines
c'est un très beau résultat france pour
sarine donc on va continuer à le
soutenir
donc la prochaine fois qui commence dans
quelques instants quelques secondes en 3
e année de stage donc son aura les
blancs jimenez aymen ben wright 9 guinn
wesley is wight 9 heures kane est ce
qu'ils disent allez c'est parti
allez lens paris iv et sow qui a changé
sarine qui a changé par il a gardé peter
il a joué entre la sortie de tahiti avec
le cavaliere mais j'ai une cape en fait
ils n'ont pas que c'est au grain de riz
ouais il joue tonnes chose de changé ils
essaient de voir aussi ce qui se passe
et dans quelle pollution et 20 il se
sent mieux par rapport à ce que j'ai à
ce que justo
à l'école nous augmentons mille proches
de lecco de zoom a tu entendras buts par
saison oui mais moi j'entendais quand je
ne sais pas
très glam hunting parle pas souvent
petites plaies gouët il est ainsi faite
sur les genoux
et des biens qui franchement on en a
parlé la semaine dernière déjà dans son
match avocat madame esso joue mais c'est
très bizarre il assure une caisse en
bois et il est un genre accroupi en fait
et il a prouvé sur un portable sur une
chaise de gamer qu il a posé
l'ordinateur lycée classique à côté et
il faut comme ça moi je le vois pas ce
que c'est la caméra de deux ans
peut-être de caméras d'ici et la camaro
droit de carrière pour être sûr qu'il
touche pas on va parler avec sa rive et
franchement
juste quand je joue trombes d'eau et
doute écouté accroupi comment tu peux
jouer pendant quatre heures comme ça et
est en plus battre
battre caruana et la refaire la même
chose contre sarine
donc bon et là c'est tout man is rich
août voilà mais c'est pas tape-à-l'oeil
table chez toi tu sais pas c'est quand
même pas où clairement dans une position
inconfortable on force mentale explose
là soupire je
sais pas mais ses qualités ludiques
handicap
parce que parce que ouais j'sais pas un
je pense que quelqu'un t'a 81 34
secondes soit n'hésitez pas rester un
problème des moyens financiers ge
contenant mais jusqu'où style
table le maire guy le mec ouais largeur
aux coudes sait s'il faut deux chaises
pas être table et une chaise longe le de
chaises regarde quand il avait trois
candidats étaient tous chacun large
peschel déroulé lors d'une scène dit oui
mais il ya ainsi sur la saône en bois ou
en limitant les regarde grippe a sont
justement je crois que volontairement
livré une chaise doute basique web
portable sur la chaîne justement pour se
concentrer sur mon jeu il pas un peu
fort d'entrée n'est
pas un peu mon des marques sont rédigés
de la main
je comprends
un
don je crois que vers l'asie va gagner
dans ce match il peut se payer d'ifa
même coup sûr bon ça dépend de
ce pitch s
s'il ya 2 le speech et je pense qu'il a
racheté une belle petite chaise
effectivement
très pur va faire une apparition comme
sa
petite chaise hâtif les émissions
australe sur vos mains
là beaucoup de travail que les chaises
d'accord pour changer les choses et là
n'est ce
pas mais tu vois nouveaux candidats ils
ont tous leur chaise différentes et là
je trouve que c'est un kama dessinons
enfin en défense en masse rapporte tu
mets des choses normales et puis juste
avant les jo
je trouve que je trouve que de
fuir sa chaise ça faire un peu
j'aime pas trop
top niveau honnêtement que je comprends
beaucoup de gens petit mal tout ça mais
bon ça va quoi c'est une chaise pas la
bouche des chèques
ouais ça
m'arrangerait écrasèrent mon avis si je
pouvais mettre vip framboise et je me
ferais malheureusement jusqu'à
la fin de la structure des paniers hors
symétrique
ces structures de phyllida en aveyron le
sien
notamment
le retrouve bien haut ses positions
ok c'est également
la pression troublante quand même qui a
plus de possibilité car structure ce
qu'ils on n'a
lui c'est pas les politiciens peu chéro
assénant extra grand chose en fait je
pense qu'ils attendent un peu dans ce
cas se passe et mais tu vois dans ces
pollutions le seul et il est fort il est
pas con tricoter il est bien meilleur
que ça rime qui lui comprend que - ouais
mais tu as et il le fait bien c'est un
petit refuge plus au
final
au final
ça arrive qui encore mal autant à 20
secondes contre et 2014
après l'argent il y en a
assez facilement sur ressort à chaque
coup de traits à
calculer au bout des six passes sur les
crises des poussées
on va voir s'il craque ou pas les
obtenir il fait un peu des plus là
dedans moi
est ce qu'il faut c'est surtout qu'ils
ne pourront pas dans les cinq dernières
secondes sur la culture je n'arrive pas
à rester un fou à flots et qu'un petit
matin mais bon un vaisseau il attend
juste le temps qu'il est plus que 2 3
secondes et là il va essayer d'accéder à
la colle
un petit saut qu'il veut pas arriver à 6
ces deux parties d'affilée qui ferment
quand même
ouais
ces deux tubes et trois aides à mort et
d'amateurs pour taper sur
f7 on oriente clairement passé tortueux
à damas de m cette seconde affaire d'âme
et 8 3 7 est bon on va voir s'il y en a
un qui tombe
cinq cavaliers prendre avec elle des
caps rossi qui était intéressant sous
16e tour
s'il n'est pas très bien c'est quand
même plutôt une bonne chose pour miral
que moi désiré descente facile pour un
ballon du mérite oui il ya moins de
questions à se poser en tout cas moins
graves du yen ne
leur en laissait traître ayant requis
son vis-à-vis de l'ascension cep 33 se
suffisent à
l'accident
mais j'ai fait un voyage pas
d'un mail 8 et foule ce ne soit pas
bafouée si ça ne m'écoute pas dina tant
il est mal autant
cavaliers ont des espaces
trois couronnes
actifs navré mais mais mais ça c'est un
magicien attention
et la tendance est bien en train de
craquer complètement wesley
bagarre donner du sang sur sa chaise et
a gardé trois caméras évidemment tu veux
inviter jean michel et sur une pièce
très content avec
le four en russie ce qu'il faut en
dessin qui va échanger à bala il aura
une finale gagnon ouais non mais en fait
tu vois c'est sa fenêtre qui rentrent
donc beaucoup de parties car les radios
ouais on va vraiment que
que dans ces moments en fait de jake
scott il est vraiment dans l'asthme et
une confiance générale de touristes
extérieurs satour variété d'options je
sors
un cerf-volant et sarine qui commence à
prendre le lead dans ce match avec 1
01 10 avouent en trois plus
de
[Musique]
200 cas là c'est d'ailleurs aussi ça va
être le vrai truc c'est 5,4 à 1,86 je ne
dirais pas ça non c'est comment
moi ça fait longtemps je parle autant
que j'aime pas que je suis chez ma
grand-mère l'après midi
[Rires]
vous l'apprendrez 4
alors que qu'aux j'ai l'impression
qu'ici plus sérieux là il a vraiment le
regard trachée
et il s'agirait du match en tout cas à
oui c'est clair c'est clair la deuxième
épreuve ok merci hollywood
voit les gouttes
de deux secondes il est énorme et c'est
ouais mais tu vois il fait beaucoup de
bulles est il al'habitude de
cédric note d'être mal autant et du
bullet et c'est pour ça que je te dis
que plus la cadence ce qui fait
penser à la camorra
génère mais plus la cadence plus la
cadence s'accélère plus d'efforts en
fait et c'est pour ça que je pensais que
c'était de la entre un cliché d'un
ruisseau est lé plus favoris parce
qu'elle a plus ça avance plus bas en
plus ça arrive je pense à des chances
que ce match
là en terme de confiance attention
regarde la partie à partir de quels
moyens dévolus traitement il y ait eu
lui de ce projet était
prêt à basculer à mardi mais barbie est
devenu très très fort et croit la chef
de caisse mais il la
met la tête de chelsea comme ce qu'on
vient
[Rires]
on vient d'avoir l'humeur démonstration
avec extraordinaire la précision de
touche est
meilleure le mercredi
et bien sûr il ya aucune ironie non non
non tout ce qui est pour tous qui est ce
qui est annoncé
ah non pour 95 élèves s'inquiètent une
belle menace qui menacerait maths
et en plus c'est qu'il a gagné avec les
yeux ou encore les deux parties
n'ont trois d'affilée oui
cavalière
gel important person partie ouest mais
vers angers ainsi que d'autres gars d'à
côté mais je crois qu'il a prises pour
moi là tempère trois parties ça n'arrive
pas souvent astros n'ont cclat et
wassalam allemagne 6 2 6 2 2 6
6 points parce que tu ne seras jamais
est ce que tu penses qu'il fallait pas
céder 6 en fait il veut essayer de faire
une nulle pour passer à 5 ennemis et
directement
après société ni ça marche aussi
ces mois après après on m'a fait la
remarque avant la fois qu'il y avait
aussi cette
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai qu'il ne parle plus ce
qui n'est pas rationnelle n'avons rien
en ce moment du match
mais bon de faire un truc sérieux
jusqu'au bout quitte reggane plaisir
ouais parce que jusque là les tournois
et c'était vraiment one way avec toi il
a pas vraiment de
enfin
avec le sco différence de score assez
assez large
c'est vrai que là on dirait pas non à un
match vraiment équilibré
nul même si on a vu que tout pouvait se
passer
la pression pour la grand sens même du
président avec cet enchaînement qui est
ici un cavendish dans les savants
le rock est moins bien placés ici j'ai
un feuilleton qui peut arriver aucune
avec des quatre caves alliance et 5 il
ya des petites choses à faire par
l'audition partie se joue encore voilà
mais si les noirs à bien me stabiliser
bon il y aurait des gens qui doit
pouvoir s'égaliser
de ce qui se passe sur ces bruits de
trouille à tout reprendre et roanne ont
une petite tactique qui ne marche pas du
tout rester là j'ai ce qui s'est passé
il a rappelé aux trois mêmes mois je les
fais
[Rires]
ça c'est sûr
ouais mais bon je vais quand même je le
dis mais
l'idée
c'est que
ici dans cette position très fin on voit
clairement en fait que des joueurs sont
humains qui auront des heures j'ai en
plus cette erreur là en vrai c'est une
grosse gaffe parce qu'à leur niveau
d'une pièce comme ça ça arrive comme une
audience noob enfin moi à chaque stream
je le fais parce que voilà c'est garde
atypique parce que ça fait déjà une
heure et demie show bien commencé
la fatigue et le stress en même temps
rien parce que tu vois sarine maine et
le stress de mener pour la première fois
contre le sort qui classait comme la
demi finale donc c'est de taquiner
nationale contre 1 d'iguane nakamura
ça pourrait être une belle affiche et
une très belle perf parle ça rime donc
ça va être long à 5 donc là ils traquent
un petit peu
comme entre 5 et de la gorge c'est et
les gagnants dans les systèmes 100 coups
de fouet contre contre
contre
carrière qu'il y ait des gagnants ou
deux joueurs à courber tic
y en a trop de plus d'un nous pas
d'aller le
contraste à cappelle nom
est vraiment et actes la partie dédiée
c'est comme ça en fait de voir mais
pendant toute la partie apparemment j'ai
dû commander
l année pas regarder
décortiqué à l'avantagé d'agir est pas
resté malgré lui il va extraire
la cape est énorme c'est passé moi
j'étais mort de rire
si jouer dans la partie contraint à une
irlande et c'est ça le beige
et
non c'était c'était un 1800 et 4700 il
s'est départi samedi
qu'est ce que c'est drôle à tout prix
jouer un coup il tient un stylo à
ressorts
[Musique]
il cliquez sur le stylo pour faire
marcher marque son coût y re clic et il
m'était le stylo sur sa poche de chemise
le mec qui donnerait plus de temps et à
chaque fois il faisait le même truc qui
me tester l'auto je suis après quelques
essais et pour noter et entraîné à qui
il veut et il indiqué et franchement ce
que c'était vraiment un truc la loire
est tellement drôle tellement en plus sa
partie de moi c'est bienvenu mais partie
commence à dérouler c'est vraiment
énorme terme en aidant les
balayeurs face à boncourt ans à la
presse qu'il pourrait essayer d'aller
donner la tour je pense qu'il va faire
je pense que solis et la tête assurant l
emploi et des mois sur la sur la rangée
à
tour prend qui va les prendre et c'est
matt estimates imparable un ski avec un
maillage étroit dans le course de côte
et qui arrivait à tenir
ok donc du coût 6,6 donc ce 6 1 en y
arriver
ouais et donc ceux qui maintenant on a
les blancs dans ce match je pas dans les
charts vous avez de la jeu contre les
joueurs avaient des manies des
trucs bizarres
j'essaie contre le tour les gars faut
croire
si c'est contre stouff les gars faut pas
raconter sa nacre et a tenu
bon je sais pas si je devais le truc
comme ça
sacré
les joueurs d'échecs sont quand même
sont quand même c'est spécial mais la
zone et râler
je n'ai pas de souvenirs en tête le
joueur qui m'a fait bizarre
peut-être un mélange fait un trou dans
les joueurs ont tendance à me donner des
pièces couture
et cela c'est c'est d'être prêt si la
chance mais bien les touche pas
ou t4 pression semble elle avait plus
mauvais 1,5 sous espèce
qui la raconte dans cette position qu'il
aime bien receler avec les oranges et 6
tailles voir page 5
la buse quillan ou partager d'atlas
dégueulasse
et bien autres merci
non ça c'est horrible
tout cela dont le chat la seconde et des
kivu travaux les transpire à grosses
gouttes c'est son premier temps à sa
retraite
ça cool ça coule
tout le monde arabe par contre ils
jouent enfin qu'il pose tout
ceci dit c'est trop long ouais bah quoi
çà çà çà çà déjà vu on va jouer si
l'adversaire babette ont maintenant
selon votre âge où se déroule non mais
si l'une des parties quand on a beaucoup
là on n'a pas le droit de nous noté
avant mais moi quand j'en ai georges pas
14 15 ans mais mon entraîneur très
courante est doté notre groupe auquel on
pense avant de jouer ont vérifié ce
n'était pas une connerie et après
seulement les notes reçues samedi moyen
d'un démo technique vous me le permettez
maintenant on n'a plus le droit de lui
mais du coup il y en avait justement des
petits malins qui notait une connerie en
liberté vers d'avant crise est ce que tu
vois que la réalité ça tu va regarder
tous y est sûre ça fait du bon pied
qu'est-ce qui est là près du cercle et
d'esther trop qui va être donnée à
d'armé en fait finalement il faut autre
chose à
33 quoi à la dame que perdu la dame de
sauter
de sarenza
j'ai passé
je voulais d'affilée la hes-so qui prend
en lutte avec 7 points
las la place à la plus l'iphone qui
reviennent
donc à ces nouveaux orages et surtout
jusque là ça coince et qui perdent deux
parties sur deux bassins genre deux
dépôts de données claires
il a donné deux pièces ont un coût salut
etc si ça luxe et salut à toi social
thouet
c'est le patch et al il y avait celle ci
ces scènes franchement on a quand même
un peu dommage pour l'instar d'un mirage
prend des risques il ya un budget
il n'a pas peur il varie beaucoup à ces
ouvertures six astronautes à la cause
c'est quoi l'ouverture gambie damoclès
sais pas si on a déjà les plus lus du
match
on a eu déjà eu droit dès ce thème de
londres on a eu droit à des cavaliers f3
un petit peu hasardeuse
et là c'est le premier vraiment con
qu'on voit que tous les coups dans sa
raquette timmy crabes ouais j'ai plein
de choses donc ces îles et il est petit
bien préparé car même sarine pour les
blancs
en dessous de leur temps
c'est la victoire
voilà où en fait non le score il est à
de leur nom oui c'est la victoire en
fait le score global il affiche en bleu
tous à côté de leur nom et après tu
allais les scores dans chaque danse
chaque porte sur nos marges donc en 5
plus une fois que 8 5 5 en trois tailles
à 2-1 pour l'instant pour sow et en une
cuisine et le score que sont pas encore
enlevé mais c'est le score de la
dernière fois enfin c'est l'histoire de
7,2 donc je pense que tu es sont contre
caruana et du coup le bus ne sont pas le
regarder pour l'instant il ne marche pas
donc voilà ouais ça va leur vendre un de
ce corps soit moi qui le touchent ses
classes comme directement moi juste prix
l'image qui viennent d'eux pour la
médecine mon truc mais je n'ai pas
changé quand même c'est impossible
s'est désolé de tt d'ambiance voilà une
question que l'horloge d'échec de bonne
qualité maria plein de
le pendule un pendule fischer comment ça
fait sept ans que je
peins extraire au bon dieu attend
sur le cd j'étais en charge charge des
gt dgt pendu d'échec tu as trouvé ma
place tout est très bien il ya c'est
ainsi vous
arrêtez de me livrer
jeu vincent variante il ya aussi la
lavables la boutique de dijon c'est une
battante je sais pas si je pense qu'ils
font du matos et vent de l'est chez qui
la concerne l'ensemble des grumes donc
va voir ce que je connais pas son échec
donc là sur alpha échec sur google plus
physique commandes et
après il ya d'autres magasins mais
travailler avec kevin on va cette
embellie dsk mais on va envoyer là
y'a plein de full wet en laissant très
très bien dès qu'un hybride bouquins des
stocks et ceux qui parlent tout seul
encore là il est en train d' encore de
gagner là bas il gâte la gorge et après
il va dire un truc mais je sais pas ce
qu'il a dit a dit je vais super
milliards de pertes là il a les blancs
h j'ai vraiment l'impression j'ai
vraiment être c moi mais j'ai
l'impression que depuis qu'il a pris le
vide sarine
il
je sais pas il est comme une sorte de
excès de pas de confiance mais de
deux
relâchements way et finalement il fait
pas bon ça fait un peu de la merde
à cela les as
âgées foule
parce que tu sais pas à quel degré il
est en fait s'il a les assassinats de la
mère de marié ouais l'élu s'est à
chaque achat qu fois que les nouvelles
pulsions à chaque fois il regorge assez
joli baroud qui fait parce qu'on veut on
voit que la sacrifier nos qualités pour
mais la tourbe est un
développeur
cerveau donnez
donc l'a86
8,6 la houle à ceux qui qui s'est
vraiment repris dans ce match alors il
verse encore une demi heure 34 minutes
cette portion sera de la partie avant la
pause avant la pause parce que
les pauses chaque portion sauf un budget
je vous rappelle donc cette partie on
fera une courte pause de publicité et on
reviendra pour la der de meilleur d'eux
l'x et mais tu vois ce qui encore une
fois toutes parts de connexion
et pour le budget ça risque de buter
tour en
roumanie guillard jazz rocard alexio ce
jour deux ou trois ans au coeur c'est ça
le pire ah ouais
je sais qu'il ya oui des genres déchets
qui sont appuyés les gars janvier une
chose les shoots et déjà
je ne sais pas du tout
ce serait bien qu'un mirage stoppe
l'hémorragie 1 ça me joue bien aussi fut
un temps où je ne vais pas trop mal
mais jamais derrière moi ça me et
intérêts aux
cavs bien sur youtube
tous les
ans la compet la con mais à la deuxième
il ya ce premier
comment ma mère
à la compet ok bah
oui on a on est en demi finale c'est la
première demi finale
donc sosa rin et la deuxième demi-finale
sera du coup jeudi à 23h30 les gars
c'est un peu tard pour vous mais
j'espère que vous serez nombreux un
sénateur week end la répéter les
vacances aussi donc deux raisons pour
rester avec nous jeudi soir 23h30 pour
la finale avec nakamura contre ding
dong nakamura l'un des gros favoris de
la compétition qui est vraiment très
très fort
dans toutes ses compétitions et en sans
oublier cette guitare et dinh qui comme
le numéro 3 mondial c'est pas n'importe
qui donc du coup c'est un très très très
beau match et donc on verra un peu ce
que ça va donner la cedh alors c'est pas
encore ça va dépendre de deux des
candidats enfin des deux finalistes qui
vont se mettre d'accord ordre un horaire
ce week end apparemment peut-être selon
sami ben on sait pas encore
et du coup trippante rabat sera sa
mémoire du cours sera encore répondre
présent pour la demi finale
et pour la finale s'est pas encore
des chances aussi soit pareil mais ça
dépendra désormais
c'est vraiment trop trop tard je pense
qu'on passe notre tour c'est vraiment un
transit matin ouais je pense que la
finale ils essaieront d'impôts
selon vous donner le sens qu'on tenait
qu'à moi pour moi il devait quitter
jeudi
intéressant c'est que les pièces comme
ils choisissent un peu les eaux à carole
du douar américain à nouveau la cei vous
l'après midi les trésors d'un kamouraska
vous faire sur le trip donne envie qu'il
est mort
il va jouer qu'on vous dit que vous sera
la prennent pour lui dit qu'il a joué à
7h30 du matin après je me dis que c'est
un gars matinale mais moi je joue à 7
heures du matin
c'est là que je me couche donc ça déjà
c'est pas ce serait un facteur qui
impactera ou pas les choses sur le march
et oui pour moi
mais on oublie même partout il perd
autant en plein de fois match de vue
j'ai suivi le match à l'ibère autant
mais lui aussi un nom mais je pense
qu'il va être un très très gros scores
moche pour moi je pense que je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas de match
mais je pense pas eh bien je fous pesos
direct intéressante vient d'acquérir des
princes
là bas il a raté
sa reynard à la sarine arrêté bien
faire dans le temps dans l'autre sens il
fait il fait cavaler prend un cadre d'un
point 4 ou de cette plage est sûr qu'à
val de cesse d'informer ses je défends
17 il ya là un vrai qu à l inverse il un
jeu on va revenir à quoi il ajoute
inverse est écrit avec un bélier cette
ex province est et du coup il a regagné
donc il est un peu mieux que dans
cavaillé ce qui est mieux que d'en
dessous il ya des plans des quatre qui
est
isolé mais ça reste quand même ça reste
quand même un casting très également dit
alors 10 mai opel mais bon il a fait une
partie je crois qu'en ligue chinoise ou
un truc comme ça pour ça vaut deux
joueurs chinois
tout autre comme ça je sais pas
exactement parce que en fait pour être
éligible au grand prix me semble qu'ils
vont permettre qualifiant candidats en
début d'année prochaine il fallait avoir
au moins une partie classique dans la
dette il a fait une partie
il ya vu que les branches les gens en
ont marre
février mars de votre chaleur et même
pas pu participer je crois qu'il a joués
genre comme ça parce que b 5 serait un
coup sur coup le tableau peint ses cinq
habitants b6 et bloqué un peu la casse
ces quatre dames c'est ça
pour ce qui est demandé d'auditionner
lmnp
donc les lignes après je sais pas si
c'est peut-être ça trompe énormément
entraîné pendant une alliée au fait
qu'on va pas vu sur internet l'a
quasiment pas je pense qu'il a tilté
applique avec les candidats une activité
je pense parce que pour les candidats
avaient jusqu'à ce que vous avez suivi
mais bon il ya les huées et beaucoup de
débats sur la sq on maintient ce qu'on
annule et céréales 8es pour annuler ans
tous français et en chinois et la
protection était beaucoup plus
compliquée l'école qu'ils fassent des
véhicules interdits elle a eu quelqu'un
de très lointain
400 parties
et le vide c'est arrivé au pire moment
pour la salle est de devenir vraiment
non mais il a fait il a eu quoi il a
fait une
belle
oui mais même ces mêmes pages 14 ans je
pense est pire que ça soit un
hébergement de qualité un mois semaines
ou trois semaines à moi tout seul tout
seul isolé
à l'hôtel sans pouvoir bien se parer du
coup que ce soit physiquement que ce
soit et chaque événement pour le tournoi
et en plus mentalement et enfermé dans
une chambre d'hôtel avant pour moi
pendant un mois
et je pense qu'il a traité complet
autour rendre au championnat il a fait
la fin très mauvais tournoi et il
perdait beaucoup de parties tu vois
c'est quand même genre dim qui avait pas
par a dû pendant quasiment commun sans
peur il arrive encore jeune en par trois
quoi enfin tu sens qu'il est pas d'en
faire la sélection des candidats
allaient complètement gagnant matinée
puis sauvait miraculeusement
ouais mais n'était pas dedans choristes
donc bon meding ça reste quand même un
des indes est vraiment mineur de liszt à
toi qu'en 20 ans en 47 15 ans qui lie le
jeu contre contre neto avant le match
vous et que évidemment que la fin je
comprenais pas plutôt que ding où carla
on cale sa vie parle de jim comme si
c'était vraiment à
quoi donc ça serait aussi une fois on
croit que c'est interdit les voyais bien
que je trouve un peu décalé genre si
vous étiez coincé sur une île déserte
avec un joueur
tchèque at elle répondu digues ce qu il
pose qu'il hyper intéressant comme
personne et il perd prend aussitôt
c'était quoi ce jusqu'à la fin de
tradition ils désavouent débattre je
sortirai pas le goût de mûre et
comme c'est parfois difficile il n'y a
pas de barrière de la langue un gentil
ça sera cool de voir j'étais aussi là
pour moi non il s'est préparé il s'est
entraîné
hyper x plupart
avoir c'était intéressant
une vraie
embellie sur l'internet contre nakamura
non mais c'est pas c'est pas les noms
mais je prends n'importe quel joueur sur
la planète à part car c'est normalement
ya quatre matches enfin après presse où
il arrive à tenir mais les sinon tu as
même maxime il a du coup de main entre
l'an dernier il avait battu car c'est
non donner fière ouais j'ai fait un
match extraordinaire est contre et
contre naka c'est aussi pas mal je pense
j'ai l'impression pas mal aussi
psychologique parce que la
casse a toujours été la bête par maxine
il a surtout envie d'être s'être
fracturé
le pied auront jamais il arrivait
justement certains s'interrogeaient il a
moins joué et on a vu les dents une
formation fusion que disent
les firouz jacques centre que je vois
qu'elle soit en plus et enfin être et je
joue beaucoup et j'ai pu tout il se
prépare qu'on a enfin il travaille
beaucoup et
après le blick c'est un bon mais ça a
ses limites et
c'est un niveau tu progresser il faut un
toit de chaque fois que travailler
vraiment et les blitz c'est pas
forcément ce qui va te ds qui voit la
patte emmènera qui est sur une île beyer
je pense que tu peux trouver assez
facilement 7
à 3 en échec
bien si on part dans leur échec mais
alors on va essayer d'être sérieux
[Musique]
j'enlève une idée mais c'est pourquoi en
fait c'est parce que carl scène ok je
trouve qu'il est intéressant anding star
il faut aussi l'échec et non mais
[Musique]
c'est vrai pas pour survivre en fait
pour survivre c'est un non sens
moi je prendrai quelqu'un que j'estime
débrouillards oui forcément je
pense que je partirai pas trop avec
murray mais pas avec steve richards pu
laisser la place à la noyade assurée
il me prend de temps à jouer a reconnu
que
si on disait un petit top 10 par exemple
le top 10 mondial
on va mettre au point des parloirs quoi
exactement fait
ouais moi je la prends aussi je n'ai pas
besoin
[Musique]
moi
j'y pensais pas ce qui est ok il venait
à
quitter et il est malin il a souvent des
remarques très très intelligente trouve
quelque chose c'est pour ça que je
pensais que que
faites vous avec 45
karlsson
faites partie vous
jai guerre on peut rêver aux lèvres et
je pense qu'on va se marrer devant
l'entrée si le service qui va les
atteindre je cherchais des bananes ou
mourir
affirme sa je partirai pas fait rosir
crois jamais trop longue qui menaçaient
même pas on a repensé toute attention
comment tu me prends pas ce que
j'aime et fier aux un an parce que il
malartic ou trop individualiste
à rognonas mashaie moi j'aime bien les
vannes pour toutes les classes
qui
pose il ya des cheminées sous
bois après sa partie sud et regarde ta
les chemises hawaïennes atom il aime
bien mais ça passe
quand ça va reprendre des joueurs sans
talent et l'arbitré pense pas en parler
dans le micro
moi je vous rendrai pas d'un cas ça
c'est sûr ah non non c'est moi
c'est un moment que fatou quand même la
marque de fatou ouais on n'est pas
forcément
très gentil ben moi j'ai un truc sont à
barra et y lier le top-12 c'était cette
année je crois est à mon avis bien ado
qui a fait une arme de grands maîtres et
qui a engagé une part conjugaux ou qui
en a qui vient avoir apparemment mal et
on lui tire tient sa part qu'il tentait
d'arrêter ça je pensais plus tard et il
analysé l aveugle pendant un petit
moment avec avec
barbie il est m ta peine 4,5 entre les
former dans la vaste mission quoi il est
venu et en fait il est intéressé par ces
positions ont évolué parle pas et je
trouve que c'est génial
non mais un joueur à 2007 qui devait
aborder pour voir la partie alors que
tout est nul en tête à côté de lui tu
vois je sais c'est pourquoi et ensuite
on s'en fout du reblochon forte atténue
le jeu pas dans les actes aux ânes ont
au contraire
intéressé par la position et il veut
parler que j'aime beaucoup dans des
jeunes mme amara a très bien connu et
qui sont quatre ont obtenu du coup
j'espère à jeudi jeudi soir 23 romande
il passionnant faire signer aux baraques
et mythique une chante
qu'est ce qui change grossesse que c'est
lui
pas sur
ses push en sauvant lors d'un bouquin je
pense
d'avoir un avare assinie soir internet
il improvise pas pour une partie sur
internet la chaux c'est
surprenant
tallinn et carassins ouais ouais bah il
a fait une très grosse blague
malgré ses
doutes en fait moi c'est un joueur que
j'ai toujours aimé
par son esprit de compétition par baril
et hyper fort quoi il à 27,70 si les
jeunes mais en fait ils n'étaient pas
beaucoup invité dans les compétitions
force pétition quand même dans le coup
pendant qu vide pendant que sa base en
disant que ce sont les mêmes et le da a
été rarement invités alors qu'ils
avaient le même vélo voire plus que
certains joueurs invités qui sont sourds
à la et j'aime bien je suis là c'est que
c'est un joueur qui joue vraiment
toujours pour la wii mais il a un style
de jeu car il est intéressant et que du
coup c'est un genre que manger mettrait
tout le temps en fait parce que bon bah
il avait dit à gros point d'ouverture
oui mais il est
arrivé parce que maintenant il a 22 77
andrée il y avait de 1750 et avenue
beaucoup parce qu'il joue db3 ils vont
être non pas n'importe quoi et
maintenant tu as l'impression qu'il ya
bien stabilisé d'ouverture avec il
est quand même bien plus en confiance
quand tu vas
dans le match contre sarine c'est un
très très bon match
on va encore j'ai beaucoup aimé ce match
et jouer gardien mais il se faisait sur
mac et il avait du mal pour finir ma
partie et sarine qui se battent et qui
ont comme un grand champion dans ce
match mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
gilles rapide
mais c'est vrai que l'inde avec maps est
impossible dans ce match même s'il a
paru m'a vachement mal de tête et fêtera
le parking
sur des questions disait qu'il avait
l'impression de jouer contre 5
ouvertures
qu'après d'un bel effort mais ouverture
des fêtes
la génération russe duda de boeuf vient
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que tu penses de
douze heures de
dubaï à la fameuse polémique trouve
ainsi pu moi aussi complètement heureux
j'avais pas trop car
la vie des choix politiques
et je pousse et cardiaques et qui a
lancé la polémique en disant que c'est
embrouillé a sous entendu que c'était
une trahison envers de tout le travail
pourrait en scène contre allan luce
laïque et voilà très bon exemple d'un
exercice bien sûr précis ne va pas se
mettre arrêté de m'entraîner
car c'est là un réseau où les quidams
aussi j'avais
vraiment
non mais je veux dire ok il est par
contre eu de patriotique je sais pas
quoi mais abandonnée du boeuf gras comme
étant non mais en fait de bois fou
travail de 45 depuis depuis 2010 3
depuis avant même les candidats depuis
avant tout ça donc on ne va pas
s'arrêter de travailler alors que ben tu
vois oui oui mais je trouve que c'est
une mauvaise mentalité sa part parce que
maintenant j'ai même vu un poids de 1 un
angle à nantes en a qui en plus lui s'en
fout il est indien il n'a rien à ce
sport eh ben ils disaient que les échecs
il a évolué et que maintenant avec fin
c'est normal de faire ce genre de chose
et moi j'ai bien aimé que ça passe que
vous 50 la fin du mois va
sinon tous les joueurs ont pris plus tôt
le parti d'une botte à part quelques
autres russes qu'on se retrouve et tu as
vu ce qu'il a dit mais bon bah oui qu'il
se foutait acceptable ouais ouais il
était bon qu'il a pété vient d'elle
c'était bidon qu'il a déjà remercié que
c'était dans les prépas de bave qu'il a
obtenu le meilleur prix voilà c'est ça
mais bon sens qu'il ya comme un petit
peu de chance pas un époux et son talent
il ne s'est pas prête je pense qu'il va
être politiquement correct mais
non bien sûr mais bon parce que la boj
je pense que ce qui se passe est ce qui
va plus jeune équipage et c'est dommage
parce que c'est un bon deal it war il y
avait un début mais ils vont de punir
part ça on est pro à part du match je
trouve que c'est ridicule
en plus j'ai vu une interview du bois
pas justement qu'il réagissait donc a
produite ou d'interviews stade de leur
vie d'avant
il précisé même s'ils voulaient s'en
foutent et halluin qui nous ont fait
très beau en vous rendant ici mais je
disais
déjà l'accord d' accord verbal de
retravailler de quinssaines je sais que
c'est un mot qu'on travaille écrit mais
tu as quand même des périodes creuses
à vous
les candidats terminent tard où les
candidats qu'ils savaient même pas que
c'était une époque est légal et baa2 sur
l'utilité d'accord qu'en seconde et
quarantaine sur l'a12 quel que soit
l'adversaire il est tombé que c'est des
poulaillers il ya le départ de suite
hier à bassar eu d'amour
les jeux que même karpov même qu'un
phoque s'est prononcée se passe tu as lu
non
bah il disait que ben pourquoi pas voilà
mais à la fin il disait que si à une
épaule est payé pour jouer par l'egypte
est bien là du coup ils pensent que
c'est contre l'esprit patriotique pas
quoi qu'il devrait plus jouer en équipe
moi je suis pas d'accord en fait enfin
moi c'est différent été joueur
entraîneur enfin pour moi c'est vraiment
différent je ne sais pas dire
là dessus après ces visions des choses
hein tu vois il est russe est bon c'est
vrai que souvent c'est pas pour pour
venir mais des fois certains ans
vu
vizio indivision antifer différentes de
ils sont hyper
patriotique en fait un petit peu trop je
pense et
je vois regarde fischer c'était la
russie contre neveu contre nice et
schirrhein seul contre tous appellent
alors une thèse d'un court texte est
payante
bien entendu c'était toujours tous les
rustres ensemble en fait c'est depuis ce
moment là te souhaiter russe puisque son
ensemble est vrai final pas maintenant
d'un coup tu as un russe qui travaille
avec un autre champion du monde parce
que ben voilà on abuse pas certain mais
toi
franchement où travaillent 400 c'est
quand même pas n'importe quoi je pense
que le mot clé par contre à la 40e place
et le monde bien sûr mais c'est ce
qu'ils disent est de ramener la période
ça s'est su ce monstrueux et momifiées
là il a dit qu'il a avec l'egypte
adjoint
non mes
jeux auxquels je suis content que tu
pense comme moi
heureusement ouais ouais c'est vrai que
moi de penser autrement se mettre
d'accord
mais bon
on lui demande qui finance ce moment où
balancer les classes avoir cédé joueurs
en fait tu vois les joueurs tu vois
genre car 120 communes comme et
regagnent un peu d'humour
2 millions voilà et d'obliger en r non
on n'a aucune idée mais il
continue à payer en plus d'égaler là il
est content il arrive à l'avancé que la
mère
la vierge reprocher qu'il était très
content de son niveau de jeu etc
et puis l'argent n'a pas d'odeur si
bordeaux quels que soient les résultats
tous les
mois en fait été assurée quand même de
gagner quand même une belle salade moins
que tu gagneras et les miss ont mis
un million c'était peut-être 20 millions
en tout et jean raby 11 pour le hockey
en vissant du web enfin c'est beaucoup
et au final
non mais en fait ce en toute fin
caraïbes et du tonnerre déjà
multimillionnaire s'en fout de la sueur
ce qu'il veut c'est être champion du
monde et conserver la couronne
qui après aller les sponsors aussi qu'il
va financer et l'espagne ça aussi non
mais je pense que
là l'argent c'est même pas de
ça on peut pas bien même chose pas mais
bon café les plans c'est assez clair
c'est je pense le conseiler ces prêts
surtout les surtout les
ce qu'a récemment
par le site a donc c'est plus c'est pas
moi qui alcatel qui n'a plus qu'à
l'attention
ouais mais ça va suffire à droite et
j'avais
très bien qu'il arrive à sauver la nulle
manière à ce que ces mesures il se bat
et c'est ce dont il n'a encore osé je
pense qu'il n'a tient à lui qu'il était
le meurtrier
la lumière puisqu'ils doivent mobiliser
cavaliers quand vous utilisez le milieu
droit c est ce que je peux à venir
manger le cavalier et le tulle ici en
fait déjà le roi et d'aller manger
durable
je décrirais pas je mange et aura pas
d'entrée avec ton renault trucks et à
cinq essais nul à travailler 3 5 il a
raison il faut trois quarts des
impressions ici ok nul son fils est
il reste à portée
sarine qui passe sur son b3
care moody pour conseiller comprendre
l'art cours en fait moi ma vision des
choses à ce niveau là je te passe
coûteux vente avant sa mise mais faut
pas tarder les modules pour comprendre
ce qui se passe
donc je sais pas quel ton niveau 1
killer joe mai
mais l'ordinateur c'est enfin c'est
vraiment un outil
vraiment qui va t'aider à comprendre
vraiment
bah moi tu est forte
parce que quand tu es fort ok tu avais
un bon crédit à
2716 quand même sur sur le fait que tu
dois avoir un entraîneur qui veut avant
tout est parti
quel ordinateur parce qu'il parle pas et
c'est différent l'ordinateur il a donné
des indications qui va voir en matière
ça c'est une erreur face au dollar et
par contre il dira jamais pourquoi
le choix tu es capable il est plus ou
moins facile la vie difficile aux
manières ce qu'on voit c'est à quelqu'un
qui la tv
puis après c'est aussi beaucoup les
coûts de l'ordinateur c'est aussi
beaucoup basé par sur le calcul en fait
donc là attention et du coup il va te
dire ça c'est bien pas se tromper
qu'elle vient une tactique et que nous
on voit pas on sait pas donc en fait
c'est vraiment pas pas cool alors que
tard entraîneur qui te dit tiens il
explique avec des mots ce qui se passe
dans la religion et pourquoi
espace-temps pas du tout soit c'est
qu'un ordinateur ils sont tellement pas
maintenant qu être qu'ils vont faire des
choix que même les meilleurs joueurs du
monde parcours du mal à pourront pas
dénaturer notre cause est humaine et
donc le meilleur coût pour un ordinateur
sa dette telle khune pour un humain
objectivement d'avoir dit pratiquer ce
sera parce que courir à l'ordinateur
parce que nous on est des humains vous
pas calquer sa course
mais aussi on a trop de danger au sourn
3 mai qu'une miraculeuse qui tient là
nous haussons dangereux
vraiment l'ordinateur pour ce prénom est
pas mal de choses au point et de faire
progresser
ça ça arrive plus tard je pense quant
aux débutants quand elle est du temps
match côté conseil domaine de l'art
donateurs c'est contre productif
car non
on voit cappuccino
justement du parti comme une partie hier
les hommes de coach virtuel qui vous dit
bien joué que ça vous expliquer pourquoi
et où ça reste un coup de jeunesse et
pardonne foutu
[Musique]
de réel
oui
mais l'ordinateur alors n'attendez pas
la
course et expliquer aux calculs à ta
place tu expliquer pourquoi et les
forteresses bah oui quand tu as même
genre
c'est pas fou pions entrevoit avec le
battre pour ceux que ça venait à la foux
couleur verte sur la m +3 maintenant je
travaille c'est sûr comprends pas qu'on
donc là donc bravo à toi cappuccino six
participations point tournant la semaine
maria qui a fais à ma victoire dans le
tableau est difficile mais bon c'est
comme ça on commence doucement mais
sûrement et petit à petit en matière
progresser et ça va être cool en tout
presque coup quand on est plus que temps
gagné et voir barbazo possible rapide
déjà cela plusieurs je pense qu'un but
rapide
merci
le wat un réseau amap aucun talent est
immense et l'amant où tu puisses faire
rater donner un éclairage sur tout mais
aucun pouvoir boire aux prestations
assez partie d'entre eux guère
longtemps mieux alors et vous du coup
cet endroit là parce que l'impact de la
hausse
après le tournoi à moins de 2 milles
2700 qui se déroule sur deux ou trois
jours je
sais pas je ne suis plus en france
alors vous aussi ce
ah ouais t'as vu c'est sûr que les
tactiques vers les parties sa source à
nouveau quand on débute et
d'appréhension dans une pièce je suis
satisfait
pas
en inde un partenariat avec le club du
caniche est intéressant
c'est la police pour faits de la
tactique c'est
en fait non ça arrive ce n'est pas là
mais il y avait un mandat et pas google
n'y avait pas de mandat il y avait
d'autres champions du monde il y avait
on l'appellerait holt est en cours
d'échecs il y avait trois champions du
monde dans la salle au
sexy il avait 15 ans en moyenne et
bataille pride à landas qui à l'époque
2500 vélos qu'il avait 12 ans et des
cours à la baisse et se tourner vers
nous non mais c'est vrai et le court
unibal aveugle et bah c'est
impressionnant quoi les dépositions en
calculant que lui faisait la vague était
meilleur que moi par mon échiquier quoi
mais en fait nous en france on est un
peu
sous tes quoi quand tu vois tu fais un
cours de deux heures oh mais il paye il
n'y a pas de fatigue et la faim du coup
mon fils quand même beaucoup deux
artistes à la barre des sept heures
d'affilée on dépose le milieu avant 17h
d'échec et les gamins à la fin il voulu
continuer à faire des chèques s'arrêter
pas et tu vas voir une france des
mentalités aussi et puis le calcul vous
travaillez beaucoup le calcul sur cet
art de cour que tu avais allait
peut-être 2 3 2 heures théâtre
conditionnelle pendant le jeu
stratégique et le reste c'était
quasiment un culte de la tactique et
c'était la folie plat et j'ai fait un
stage là-bas je suis très content
d'avoir d'avoir pu vivre cette
expérience en tout cas porter en tant
qu'entraîneur et agir en tant que
latéral en tout 12
il ya aussi je pose la différence
surtout sociales qui font beaucoup de
métaux en cliquant sur elle alors un
petit français pendant douze ans qu'il
ya une vie vous pendant sa famille vous
m'ayez pas envie car design chèque par
jour parce qu'il n'a pas besoin de
chercher c'est un moyen sont sortis
enlever ces chèques en sommes maintenant
simplement cette
s'appelait travail vu très vite bien
très beau vin comme une profession un
moyen
de sortir de sa retraite lui perçu le
ouf par
ailleurs les sauts qui a crié
je sais pas ce qu'il allait
j'ai pas si tu l'as vu
l'image est
différent
les gens allongés à la sortie
gauche où tu voyais des gens qui
marchent en fait la majorité des gens
étaient plus nombreux les joueurs
d'échecs l'échelle est ce que il était
10e place cette envie de réussir
puissances rivales c'est elle qui avait
dit bien vu d'innovation il y avait une
émulation de ouf quand tu voyais quand
tu voyais quand tu le voyais que
alenda champion du monde 2005 100 lots
des problèmes où tout leur semble être
en fait l'essai était yamal de jalousie
que ça connaît tous ces sportifs ils
veulent tous ces remous du mieux et il
n'y a pas de limitation si tu as et par
exemple même nous regardes tu es en
course se soit encore déchets pour à
l'école que ce soit des fois il ya ce
que tu comprends pas où tu vas tu peux
répondre à une question jean révèle une
honte à une variante qui pense avoir
trouvé la solution
qu'est ce que tu vas tu vois que tu va
lever la main et de l'autre réponse est
en fait souvent à l'école en france en
tout cas et bah t'as peur en fait de
lever la main tu as peur du regard des
autres par rapport à ta réponse tu vois
et je veux dire une connerie on se
moquait de moi ça est en fait la base
n'avait rien à voir là bas tu avais un
cours avec y avait un mille deux cents
lots et pai land art dans le même
courant
2002 soins alors il va répondre il va
être content et
personne va se moquer il va jamais avoir
un essai tout différent en fait et tu
vois vraiment enfin abandonner j'avais
je contrains contre un gamin il d'avoir
quoi 12 ans et il avait 2102 bon très
fort et du coup on confond blix donc là
bas la cadence quand on fêtait ses dix
boulettes en faisait des bulles et
d'entraidé contre est donc en triplettes
et je veux bien gagner un gp en gagner
peut-être pas à 5 ou 6 1 et et après la
prochaine pause ils viennent c'est comme
ça il y en a et il voulait pas vraiment
jusque et genre le gard battu voix et
m'a dit maman était maintenant c'est
beaucoup et c'est cette fois ci ils
avaient défoncé et le cas maintenant et
2004 mais met juste en fait c'est
marrant quel point ils ont la plume et
6,1 tu peux te dire ok lui est trop fort
ça moi j'en ai marre de conflit
à un moment tu l'aimés 6 1 il a pris une
faille va défoncer quoi et ils ont
vraiment l'esprit vendait c'est un
espace justin y rien à voir avec la
france avec des vents à la france ou
l'europe
mais aussi pour ça que la leçon restons
forts et c'est aussi un match en moins
de s'en sortir tu vois comme tout leur
saoul minière
c'est vrai que
grâce des chèques tu vois certains qui
arrivent à voyager à travailler à
certaines choses
s'arrangent et nous a maintenant le
déchet qui voyait tout le temps
d'écouter des sponsors si génial corps
échec c'est ouvert à tous ça va avec la
supérieure en inde
alors en fait de ce que je sais par
rapport au club l'enquêté c'est qu'avec
des joueurs qui n'est pas forcément le
moyen de
accéder à tout ça est en fait
l'entraîneur qui est très connue c'est
ramesh très connu aussi grâce à ça à ses
résultats parce que la mèche il a
entraîné l'équipe olympique mais aussi
pour tous deux de grands talents indien
donc ya pas de délai qui maintenant plus
de 2500 vélos le wild a informé il a
formé jusqu'à + 4 ans m c est en fait
ramesh où lui-même paye la cotisation
est aussi paye des tournois de sa poche
a chanté un gamin qui ont pas les qui
emploient des moyens sûrs pendant près
d'un an dans les paroles ils sont issus
d'une famille très très pauvres mais
vraiment très beau match des u j'ai vu
des parents
est en fait chaque fois ils visitent mrd
pour le faire je me souviens ascarat
ingénue et a donc en fait il ya des
gamins qui ont de l'argent et qui ont
participé à tout ça et des gamins qui
n'ont pas d'argent mais il s'inscrit
mais aussi et après haïti sont
intéressés qui sont forts qui ont motivé
les joues quoi et après battu de
débrouille pour essayer de pour essayer
de faire progresser des mois plus tôt le
gamin était grand maître à présent quoi
donner à bail
ouais mais tu vois c'est tu vois avec
talent manquera mais s'ils travaillent
mais c'est pas du tout pour faire de
l'argent enfin bien sûr les gens
vieillissent et coûteux mais j'ai
vraiment au delà de tout ça il veut il
veut travailler pour
laisser pour leur échec pour les gamins
eux mêmes tout ça c'est vraiment pas la
machine à l'argent vases issus message
gagnent tant d'argent non bien sûr hélas
d'argent jamais su plein de choses comme
des cours il avait site internet il ya
plein de choses bien sûr que l'argent
est bien sûr que le plein de choses mais
il est parti de rien de base en est
mais bon une bonne qualité et sa peine
je trouve ces boules
mais mon séjour en inde en rien c'était
c'était
une tête même l'amère expérience que
j'avais vécu en niveau et chacun apporté
dans ces moments
là je t'aime question mais j'ai pas tout
lu dans le très attendu jeu par les
quelque chose nous avons eu des conseils
pour jal a d'ailleurs je t'avoue moi je
sèche rapporté la même journée mais
après ça dépend de tous niveaux aussi
mais moi ce que je faisais pas mal ceux
des exercices pendant les cours dès fois
après ça dépend du niveau pendant un
gamin que je sentais qu'il voyait bien
la position à la veille tout à fait
passer la vague tranquille et son
adversaire qui peut être moins force et
ben
en fait je les mets dans un coin il n'y
a pas des chéquiers et ils veulent
aveugle et une note luke ou sur un
smartphone est en fait chaque jeu passe
cinq coups par exemple eh ben le gamin
il peut aller voir la police y ont joué
les coups souvent sur l'échiquier pour
voir la position et après il repart sa
soirée vont continuer à jouer à la balle
et ses dépenses au niveau 6
ils voient bien tu peux mettre georges
pas
tous les petits coups 15 cours des fois
de la partie ça dépend et c'est
intéressant de pouvoir aveugle parce que
ça permet au contraire et les devoirs
des
calculs est en fait sans bouger des
pièces et pouvoir anticiper pouvoir
imaginer la position c'est vraiment
intéressant car il ya plein plein
exercice et techniques vont travailler
ça mais moi je pense que c'est
intéressant et c'est parti en fait la
tactique finale parce que quand tu
calcules en fait on parlait parce que tu
y vas une apparition donc moi c'est un
site intéressant que le travail comme ça
le très fort son genou qui parlait
d'une cliente emmené à 20 s'il continue
il est connu à belhanda il a des 1650 et
maintenant
qu'il l'a il a 16 ans non il a 26 50 il
a il a un an de moins que ça arrive plus
qui joue entre monde il ya le même
niveau mais le mec le plus clair que
même les
annonces et son génie aussi
bien aussi bon qu'à ranger aussi si un
procès que les diplômes ils devaient
attendre les deux mille lots on commence
enfin à moi j'ai envie de te dire
normalement c'est vraiment tu veux
consacrer plus de temps aux échecs de
milliers losc doit pouvoir l'atteindre
après un match vraiment avancé
mais s'ils n'ont jamais laissé quelque
chose qu'avant travaillant bien ça doit
être accessible on a plus ou moins de
nature des prédispositions c'est un bon
cru pour la mythique pas vous êtes plus
ou moins facile c'est vraiment mon but
dans la vie tu te dis à fond auquel je
parlais ici car pas joli chèque promis
ouah je
pense que tout le monde pour réussir
après commence à monter peut-être m
quand même
pas quelque chose
d'inatteignable
échec à 24 30 à 26 ans d'un
1883 vraiment le genre moi je connais un
grand maître qui a commencé à 19 ans une
belle progression et une vraie si tu
peux gagner fait à six mois il à 2030
non moi j'ai produit un grand maître qui
qui a commencé à 19 ans jeune tchèque
d'accord ouais bon bah j'ai bien sûr
avoir des facultés
voiture propre farine match c'est
dommage parce que c'est évident il a
craqué et du ballon la pression et les
malentendus temps qui revient
2030 pour la dana parti il factions qui
sait garder cela pour la cde recollèrent
ici plus beau match car ils seront quand
à expand arrière mais avec sa vie de la
perdre
minul ça a peu joué parce même s'il perd
il peut la gagner parce qu'on a on a vu
un maxime qui a par contre aucun moyen
et en a maintenant plus trois mais bon
c'est un espoir la pause la chorale on
est d'accord que
une défaite ça le met quasiment
sinon les ouvertures moi je pensais ne
pas bosser les gouvernants grave
moi j'ai encore 1800 peut-être un peu
extrémiste pense qu'avant ça
on pouvait un tout petit peu pour un
certain pouvoir au début voix mais oui
et pas travailler à fond les ouvertures
sur les avoir un petit schéma de jeu aux
savoirs de stepien comment faire ça mais
après pas des poussées et ça c'est vous
dire que j'adore gg 1700 je vais
apprendre la nageur comme la nouvelle
c'est beaucoup trop compliqué vous allez
trop vous allez trop
sur les ouvertures faites on change de
voiture encore une fois par rapport à
mon truc en inde le gamin après deux
mandats il a commencé à travailler
d'ouverture à des 1600 iso donc ça c'est
un peu extrême moi je comprenais pas
mais à un moment donné il avait 2006 en
vélo mais j'ai une histoire comme ça
j'avais qui a comme il s'appelait
d'indiens
la main il a 26 et quelques si j'ai un
trou de mémoire sont
dans plusieurs labels joué à cannes au
fijm avait défoncé 2400 euros 12 ans
et
belle boîte à kiev n'en
est
ghazi longue bien avant bien avant
maintenant il d'avoir 21 ans de temps et
avoir tout de morlaàs et le gamin
après je produis déjà dit on y va à oui
je veux contre shirov d'un parti d'un
tournoi gibraltar en tout comme ça en
fait s'ils gagnent la partie eh bien il
est déjà grand maître troisième normes
de 1500 euros et puis quand même c'est
qu'en fait ce n'est pas trop d'ouverture
évidemment il à g être quasiment ne
connais pas tous vertueux et du coup
ramesh avant la partie valoir équipes
ont du coup t'as pas vers la partition
parfois je crois les gamins il dit en
fait moi je n'ai pas d'ouverture du coup
quand je frappe étroite et josé cheikh
gamin de 12 ans fait la mentalité des
ravines tu arrives in the arab et la gb
3 il avait une leçon christelle
shirov kissir of ancien prétendant au
titre mondial un qui a eu 25 ans sur ses
rivaux pas de militants d'ailleurs au
pass 2007 à 50 et quelques années au
franc suisse c'est monstrueux et gp3 non
en fait je bête pas il ajouté il n'a pas
théorisé tranquille et voir ça à 12 ans
juste qui soit comme nous maintenant tu
vois un gamin de 12 ans il va dire mais
je n'ai pas l'âme âge d'or ce du coupage
répertoire
attendez-vous d'échec milliards et sa
page des chèques ont fait afin de
trouver de l'argent et plus tu
apprendras arthur tôt plus tu va
dépendre le hr et plus tu vas pas faire
d'ailleurs même plus loin en fait
décalage entre ce que tu connais pas tu
vas être alors que tu apprends pas
rassuré ben non pas calculé aussi là
quand tu que des bases où il est
actuellement très fort c'est envers
chaque fois être lié à toi même et à
devoir
va trouver des jeux censés boucler
quelques incidents déjà d'ailleurs c'est
plutôt que à prendre ses crocs quand le
maire de combourg trouve bien apprendre
par coeur des
jeux pouvoir des coûts reprendre ce que
vous aurez pourquoi
15,3 me casse vous exactement les mêmes
pièces dans la position
moi ce que je dis souvent en fait t'as
pas droit de jouer un coup aux échecs si
t'arrives pas à justifier ton goût et
est parce qu on m a beaucoup de gens
l'autre jour j'étais resté quand
j'étais en cours avec un élève et puis
il ya ces partis puis j'ai vu un coup
blizzard qui a été joué je lui demande
pourquoi tu as joué ça et parce que ça
ressemblait à ce que tu m'avais montrer
du coup je voulais retomber
ouais mais en fait tu veux ça ressemble
mais c'est pas la même position donc du
coup c'est pas l'impression que c'est
pas les idées et en fait pour lui c'est
normal non vérifiées sur punir et porter
la condition est né au final ben je
crois qu'il a perdu la partie mais peu
importe mais l'idée en fait ce qu'il a
joué un coup sans avoir d'idée il l'a
joué parce qu'ils pensaient que ça
ressemblait qu'il pensait qu'il pouvait
transposer dans une position qu'il
connaissait au lieu de réfléchir à une
position normale avec des coudes en mots
elle ton cerveau tu réfléchis est ce que
tu peux faire comme bon coup ben là ils
réfléchissent et pourrait se transpose
dans ce qu'ils connaissaient et c'est
pas la bonne approche simplement
j'ai entendu de
jouets
haba là j'ai fait ça parce que tu n'es
steiner premiers points d'écart ou
regarde
des joueurs à 2000 sol et de santé qui
seront notamment après focaliser sur les
ou version et qui vont répondre
par sosa a rien à voir ça n'aide pas la
bonne position mais vous déjà vu ce coup
là ils veulent recaser
et ça c'est vraiment un gros défaut de
quoi la route
on va clairement
devant les ouvertures c'est pas le plus
important avec moins d'une poignée de
l'un qui veut jouer il faut c'est
travailler avec le calcul
est calculé en stratégie aussi et les
ouvertures sévèrement après que vous
sachiez un petit peu on va dire des
bases
donc ça y'a pas tout c'est très bien
mais vous n'êtes pas besoin de savoir
beaucoup plus
là où trois c'est très bon il faut
éduquer menacé un avec avec le vis-à-vis
de la tournée et pose moi je vais devoir
d'électeur il faut prendre 2 ab attend
là bas qu'est ce qu'il est malin
je pensais cadre d'un droit g2j fait
tordre et le répétons civils sont très
bien joué de la part de michelin qui va
avoir les doutes eurent pour la dame
mais c'est aussi
le cas des antiques dominé dès que l'on
met les boules je pense qu'ils se
bouffent par le fou et le fouet par
exemple le fou et non son intention
affichée à 2 heures du matin ça arrive
de faire naître et pedro
cavadas 7 défend et la dame qui tend
ferme et résolu de gestion de stars je
vais pas y arriver je n'ai pas vu non
plus
pas ceux parmi les accros au portillon
de 800 kw 5,5
5,4 du coup dans cette portion
que ouais donc du coup
sauty domine j'ai même pas exprès en
hockey à +1 infectieux pour la blague
sow qui a plus un an ce match et
avant la bulle est donc ça hyper
intéressant parce que les bleds en vrai
c'est 50 50 je pense et sarine que très
très très bon en bullet et rien ne va
c'est quoi on va avoir de suspense pour
le bullet way
sg oui oui moi je suis bien à elle peut
parler championnat de rapide lebel
justement qui ont eu entre noël
toujours sympa si le futur roi ça ne
m'est aura préféré j'aime bien
c'est hyper spectaculaire savez la
visite
ouais je sais pas où va si on affirme ou
bien
géré roja un maxi
maxi cie vous pouvez aussi bien sûr des
partis des favoris à voir avec cannes et
celle d'acs amoureux le pis y'a moyen
moyen d'ailleurs un haka qui participent
à cette année alors que la guerre
allemand au gré de la type de show des
championnats du monde de blitz admis rod
est assez confus
mais saint cannat kaki jeu ça fait
quelques années qu'il n'a pas joué ce
championnat
mais je pense qu'avec avec avec tout ce
tournant sur internet ou cinq ans qu'il
a quatre
un peu sur l'échiquier c'est en tout cas
un mode libre c'est quand même sympa à
jouer entre que je prenne parti ça va
vite c'est plus sympa qu'un témoin
tournoi l'an tout cas moi tu composant
la louve l'insee hadaoui la table en
dehors des cas par une partie à suivre
donc du coût horaire c'est premièrement
tu peux voir avec les chiffres et
directement avec les caméras des joueurs
ak oui la pétition compenser mais mieux
mais après souvent gérard
maxime qui est un des meilleurs du monde
un cas qui concerne la meilleure du
monde ils sont jamais gagnés en fait sur
tenait
bon et la carte sim kagamé qui gagne pas
à chaque fois tu vois je crois que ça je
crois que eux ils vont en tout cas gagné
mais une année il ya great flu grippe
genre fois aussi attendus au palais
gallien rapides et ils vont toucher plus
et brics le raffinage 3,7 blitz mais en
fait il ya une partie dans le blitz dans
son abri ce genre 15-13 non 18e pinch
crois que c'est un stade neuf ans rapide
et et 18 non non rapide c'est plus que
neuf il ya 28 parties il ya beaucoup
couru partout moi c'est le vin je suis
pas un truc comme ça c'est un truc comme
ça va en fait il faut vraiment être en
forme pendant voit partir ses avoirs des
hsh man
made in marciac inauguré entre le 26
décembre et le 31 c'est le truc tu passe
noël que ce soit
trois jours pour le rapid deux jours le
blitz
toujours comme ça fait plusieurs années
que cette période ça c'est un tournoi
que je réagirais veut faire
mais pas l'unsa et pour y aller je crois
il me semble le sont que pour y aller il
faut que tu aies deux mille cinq cents
lots mais il même dans une j'ai trois
portions ce soit soit en blitz soit en
rapide ou soit en lan ensuite
je sais pas je pense qu'à 12 500
mais j'aimerais bien y aller bon je me
ferai des français partent moins nantis
dessous mais en fait un tournoi tout 950
toujours outre à 2006 trop bien que
si j'allais à l'école et
j'aimerais trop 25 50 ok je poste à 25
menés barre il faut pas qu'un mec trop
faibles qu'ils aillent voir
il ya un prix constant sur leur dieu
peut-être que c'est moi je vais
peut-être villa crime puisque si l'été
est ce que ça va mieux grâce aux où est
ce que ce bruit est encore présent parce
que lens pas menti l'osm éclipsé le
recul mais les proches de mme en fait
quelle teinte ça va mieux oui on peut
être 25 ans dit allez vous le dire avant
et même on peut être 2000 absolue ou
pour être 2700 classic sans être grand
maître
d'ailleurs chez pas les genres quel a
été le plus fort joueurs sont néanmoins
très bas y avait à l'époque il y avait
français un gars à mian il avait plus de
2600 lots n y ait plus de 2600 euros
alors que pour être grand maître il faut
deux mille cinq cent mille l énorme il
avait en 2006 en vélo ils n'étaient pas
quand m après
il va y avoir aussi des gens qui ont
fait enfin le renard
meiway 25 56 ans a
sinon c'est un peu dans le même temps il
ya une femme shera zik un joueur très
connu en france qui fait énormément de
tournois en fait on voit beaucoup cas un
joueur très talentueux je sais pas quel
âge il a maintenant
d'avoir plus de 50 en tout cas un voyage
centaine france des - voilà et il lui le
pot et c'est vraiment le plus mal chance
ils agissent par combien les normes
compromet dizaine n'ont juste pas dire
de conneries mais bon énorme
et il est monté à
2499 54
hockey sachets à la légère mais je me
crois
que justement là une partie pouvait
passer les 2500 mais en acceptant une
nulle il a refusé la nulle parce qu'ils
pensent être qu'à lyon il a perdu la
partie il ya pas eu d ailleurs ce
come-back selon les agents
non mais jamais il a une dizaine de
tombes de grands maîtres quoi
franchement ville-marie tarama title il
me devait être calmes cantate didon
durant la trêve tu as 24 99 mais c'est
le cas du risque d'être assez beaucoup à
ce sont 18 heures
je tiens à ce que sam sam alain beaucoup
à ma main jason wu shengli
jouer tchèque 18 arrive tu te présentes
non je ne suis pas grand maître n'a
invoqué son pic est attendu ça mais
quand elle reste sans être calmes tepa
grand maître demande années après avec
le poète 40
[Musique]
chez ba alors effectivement mois sur la
fidh et il a une pique à 26 donc 16
mai à canal et l'univers mettre l'équipe
dans laquelle karam karam yann aller
parce que moi je rêvais l'open de canada
il était maître je crois même pas de ça
j'ai eu énormément
en 2009
a marqué le mois malheureux en
2009 -
10h26 tout pile
et 26-22 1115 et en 2010
2010 la rd 26 32 donc 26 26 15 il t'est
pas quand m
grâce à lui on est parti sur le bullet
toof et le bullet qui est parti donc du
coup à la sarine à une demi-heure de
belote et ayez pas de pause dans les
gares l'un des meneurs de plus est à un
point d'écart c'est hyper chaud
on va voir si les salariés
sont normalement il est loin d'être
bouclée dans cette cadence aussi donc
par là c'est du 50-50 catherine bourgoin
en fait suivi complet a vraiment tout
commence il est hyper complet il est
permis et sa une par contre c'est vrai m
regardez juste regarder les lots qui
vont sur internet sarine la 3271 il
postule à 3122 donc les soldes très très
bon mais sarine l'idée est peut-être
encore plus fort on doit jouer plus en
fait en une lettre où elle joue plus et
surtout en plus sarine je pense qu'il
joue beaucoup de buts + 0 c'est moi qui
ai dit chance pas le même jeu comme
il aimait 25 secondes à jouer faut se
mettre dans les sept divisions vers
plantes bio britz et d'un seul coup pas
con avec une manette ça c'est dur at
on créé de faux calculs windows mail à
20 secondes contre ce père du trader du
coup on attend sur la pause
il est un peu court partout et ils
arrivent à se dépêtrer
sa part pas très bien ce pour bien parti
pour dire à la presse lors du net il
compte bien sur la foudre angers7 je ne
comprends rien ça va trop vite pour moi
aussi avec du tour en deux sets carrés
d'arbres celle ci voulait mener assez
m'attend h au contraire c'est très
tactique c'est très très chaud avec le
si peu de temps je suis aussi du damage
et 6 1 quand le cadre des mardis 5 il ya
trop de quoi est ce compliqué tous at il
affirmé sur la foi je protège portable
mais la salers 13h en pratique pour
exemple on a vu que ça arrive il est
vraiment capable en bullet la cavale et
2 et 3 dans prends je prends de la tour
j'enlève ma tour de l'attak du fou
très bien joué cavaliers detroit très
très bien joué dans tout ce qui pouvait
arriver peut-être parce qu'ils ne
mangent pas le fou tour laquelle a nié
cet effort du let avait des fourchettes
alors qu'adrian bullet scénario du
tableau il faut croire qu'il peut
arriver y avoue ses cendres mais on voit
qu'il a inversé il appréciative pas
beaucoup d'activité et
la petite ce qui simplifie la position
il ya plus en 80 heures il y a encore
coûté 50,5 points 4
16h55
michaël la pièce t'habitues l'a36 fini
ok donc là on va voir ce qui va se taper
avec deux points d'avancé c'est une
cuisse il abandonne 1 pour recommencer
voilà c'est une idée du sud et donc du
coup une petite chute du sud
ouest maxime mais tu vois vous avez été
la différence
non mais en fait maxime je pense pas
qu'ils s'amusaient beaucoup de bulles
est en place je pense qu'il joue un
tournoi où il sollicite alors que ça
arrive tu peux le voir souvent fort du
bullet pour s'amuser explique aussi son
lots qui est au dessus parce qu'il joue
beaucoup plus c'est sûr
voilà ma carrière et pour recoller tout
de suite là qu'on reconnaîtra c'est que
si jamais elle perd ça sera plus trois
pour cent ne sera dur avec des plafonds
qui vient de votre caution c'est lui
qu'elle est décisif c'est qu'ils sont
mieux placé il ya des couloirs pour les
gonades
faut qu'ils oublient que j'ai
l'impression que balawi la 56 beau la
première partie n'était pas dans le
rythme ouais mais peut-être qu'ils
n'étaient pas bien au niveau de
l'ouverture ça ne plaisait pas été
déclassé de changins pousse à vous
soucier ça peu de champ les sites
capables d'intervenir au 5ème
[Musique]
bien là presque g45 c'est ce que j'ai 4
c'est un coup
droit
parce que c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle qui joue mon coup cela
peut trouver des couacs et c'est encore
hélas il ya quinze jours
comme ça et ça
ça cache et la tour est donc là je
défends la est là mais qui peut arriver
car des débouchés ouverte ses chances
d'être sûr il ya beaucoup d'enjeux h41
je crois qu'elle a je crois qu'il est
tellement vie
84 parce que le h4 g5
eelv adjoint coupures soit lui soit
ok qu'est ce qu'ils étaient quatre à
risque au jour moyen fois en bullet
c'est bien d'essayer de l'eau douce
simple et si une un petit peu de temps
centraliser les pièces manoeuvre est
redevenu à mettre la pression moi
j'aimerais y avait voué sa reine qui
jouent comme moi je pense que tout
compris dans cette
[Musique]
attention il faut que j'attende et 3
il va se reprendre s'ils en restent à
prendre ça c'est ma spéciale en plus il
réfléchit beaucoup
là il avait pas concrète puisque pas
prise
le canadien sera peut-être eu quatre ok
d'accord avec la pression il n'y a pas
peur il n'a pas peur d'ouvrir son roi
ici
c'est comme les noirs mieux parce que
rares plus faible mais
ça va nous y voilà sur l'innovation au
pli
mais bon on a vu sarine et là quand même
joué très très vite avancé farmer il se
hisserait ce n'est pas impressionnant
bond il a beau être moins bien
ça reste encore vague mais pas d'échec
interne et celles des fonds d'essaimage
de ses prix une fourchette c'est dément
il fait ils finissent tous ce soir après
c'est pas fini en plus des quatre coins
froid regardez des pièces
fournies en partie d'entre eux sera bon
donc il y avait les baies
5.3 forcé
j'aimerais mieux ne pas répéter une fois
domination totale à 7,4 peut-être qu'il
arrivait un an pendant ces mois qui
avait terminé
je pense en prend deux fois tout
genre de descente je pense
bon ok + 3 2 0 semble être qui est
impressionnant la doit à tout prix que
mirallas tout de suite
jean pouvait-on faire un petit peu une
petite plage de cubains je vais pas chez
vous ça que les gens que je jeu stream
et
voilà cinq ans que je passe tout près
une technique j'ai rencontré plus tard
comment sera sur ma chaîne mais j'espère
revenir très bientôt et vous envoie le
lien ma chaîne pour ceux qui ont envie
de découvrir
daoukro à 4 qu'est ce que c'est une
pièce sillage une pièce la boulette de
saut à skis d'enfreindre alors qu'ils
doublent en
fait on n'arrête pas de se racle la
gorge ça c'est rigolo la dame qui
gagnent des deux tours et derrière des
droits qui font la même chose si bien
que les deux tours c'est très joli ça ça
ça
metric
sarine quittait l'affût de tout ça tu
vois il enfants il guidera bancs du
lycée au lait non t'inquiète mais tant
attendu et voir comme ça c'est juste
hallucinant car un essai barrot est un
sdf de 4 c et bouffe alors banon focal
pour la gagner ou quoi peut-être un
petit cavalier seul j'épuise échec
derrière il va manger à 2 et prend
aussi
à gagner une fan avec pas tous douves
bah j'espère bien quand même
j'espère bien quand même responsable
bien que un pion pour la pièce
qu'ils défendent et si en plus il ya le
progrès un échec ouais ça on parlait que
le cavalier c'est un meilleur défenseur
contre un échec parce qu'il a pas
d'échec indiqué dan je peux rien faire
grâce à ce cavalier
piola du coup est ce qu'un soldat tué
parce qu'il fait tourner le chrono il
pourrait continuer mais bien sur
l'assaut ils voient que c'est
parce qu'il le faisait pas contre contre
aby contre fabio ya vingt trois ans
qu'il avait une belle avance au temps
enfin vous allez score oui mais là ça va
très vite pas de table n'est pas ce qui
fait toile et il est retourné chez
différement tournée c'est entendu comme
ces camps risque est chiante excellent
on a gagné c'est complètement gaillon
ouais mais bon apple où il ya plein d
cheikh tall sow haddad ça prend du temps
du tout vu qu'il a de l'avancé
et là il a raison en soins c'est là le
format est comme ça ben quoi elle livre
au format low profile mais
d'un bep 3,14
c'est dégueulasse moi j'ai pas lu ce à
quoi il avait tout le monde tempo matin
elle a joué jusqu'au bas et fier que son
illustre adversaire c'est 21 croit dame
il va attendre
la seconde choc est allé mode reste 20
minutes avec dallas
interplay mais content et c'est comme ça
le format est comme ça qu on pas blâmer
les joueurs ils profitent enfin le
footsie est quasi kovacs
je pense que digg le trader dit oui le
ferai pas je pense
et je parle d'expérience que j'avais vu
non mais vraiment je viens je vais faire
je n'accable faire que les terres a dû
comme çà dire
rapport aux 87 12 after mais rapport à
l'état sont invisibles jeu d'échecs quoi
je pense pas qu'à droite on
maîtrise bien la peur de fou pour les
blancs et les noirs bien sur l'échangé
doit jouer la finale et blu un nid
farès combien de temps dans le match
pour 19
quelques parties c'est encore joindre en
cas d'égalité on a eu droit à une
prolongation et le but est donc y aura
quatre il est à souhaiter sai non plus
c'est un homme charmant
donc il y a du coup à 4 pu l'être en cas
de qualité et si à l'issue desquelles
bull étaient encore à égalité et y aura
ma maison il parle pas de moi là bas je
forme les gens sur sur le tir de forme à
ce tournoi il pousse un petit peu avec
les blancs on s'est quand même bien
mieux les assaillent sur des musiques
métisses soyons pas dupes ils calent
moins bien nantis stature non mais en
fait tu sautes sur m'intéresse c'est que
ça ça se prolonge ce soit la dernière
partie de l'étape qui passe une
partie de 20 minutes en ont une piscine
dans la même voie coup de pions tous les
cinq ans cool
de là c'est impossible de faire d'être
prouvée au vert pour les bleus mais moi
je peux pas les noirs parce que j'en ai
encore une
passerelle tour donc si c'est bien je
vais jamais dabbashi je me sens pas ce
qu'il essaie de faire des choses ces
balades à bagdad ap six cas d'enfants en
âge 4 je prends quoi la rue d'alma moi
chier c'est quoi l'idée de 9,5 frustrant
il a peut-être
non
5,3 non mais j'avais jamais vu ça ici
il a dû rater ça
comment il faut faire je prends
simplement il
ya parfois eu trois équipes arrivées là
ça ne
suffit pas on voit que se livrant enfin
c'est bien mais mon but là qu'il est
vraiment qu enfin c'est 90 villes est
bon et
parfois leur mets mais tu manges et le
fujian le cavalier bien fait manger à
justin c'est très chaud où j'ai
l'impression que demain ce que je
pourrais
peut-être en pension à venir le bateau
si attention
et chaque fois la f4 genou et je suis
troublé au stade m cad dans sfr 3g serbe
n'a pas grand chose à faire pour rien
c'est malheureusement cette fuite et
ramène à mes copains mais j'ai pas
d'échec souffrent epson qui est pas de
trouver 5 à le piaui donne c'est quand
même une grosse gaffe
échec et le cavalier est perdue je crois
olala sow qui craquent complète le gas
oil et qu'ils aient perdu 2,17
va revenir à un point ça c'est bien ok
la fait craquer wesley tu sais votre
karma c'est le cas rama de vouloir de
20,2 à
faire durer la partie bravo allez donc
la ja il ya deux dans ce transformers
elle aidé d'un chat vous êtes pour l'un
des joueurs
je peux faire une petite une petite
tradition si vous voulez je pensais pas
le d'ailleurs
son
jeu plus
je vous fais une petite
[Musique]
alors c'est encore parti très vite et
des rockets mais c'est pas grave ici il
va rockets à la main avec son roi il à
faire plus ça pour nous le sondage
regarde est parti vous avez trois
minutes pour pour pour voter sur votre
favori dans ce match ils sont rois bien
aussi
j'ai voté pour ça arrive moi je vais
voter pour sauver nos seniors atteints
il ya quand même des gens est un fait
déjà les gens votent pour le labour
munichois voilà c'est facile un mois
depuis le début je dis j'ai déjà vu les
soirs
les mêmes j'étais même morceau contre
contre rapport que j'ai que je
commentais je crois que lui porte chance
il sort d'une île élèves s'ils se
demandait qui chante sur l'équilibré ici
ça joue des deux côtés de tous ceux dont
la majorité tournent à trois contre deux
essais d'avancé même table à elle va
devoir battre sans
son chien
sur un quai des six mais changer les
pièces taillées renta excellent dame lui
essayé de faire dames 2 peut-être
impressions sur f2
et cinq
grosses constitution
xpo tu vois ça en eau en eau du chat il
ya une petite fenêtre avec sondages en
cours du dessus et tu votes
normalement lazaoui je pense que tu peux
miser les promenades favorites j'y mets
george est pas autorisée je crois que
j'ai pas autorisé
est à prendre dans cette finale et le
plomb mais quatre qui va tomber donc
c'est bien calculée de l'art de la récup
et b sol hongrois va revenir ça doit
être nul ça
c'est qu'ils voulaient voter pour moi en
fait un super
il va rester unis tous les sondages
vegas vous voulez qu'ils sondages un
petit cavalier à 6
km es16 on dirait que malika
probablement avoir des ronces et cela
seul changer nasa interne nulle
ça va mieux l'autre demie c'est jeudi
soir 1-3 à 30 milles on espère vous voir
même si leurs prêts tardive non salle en
tout cas donc on aura besoin de votre
soutien ouais parce que tout cela ce
temps là enfin c'est moi ça va chez moi
il sera plus importante
moi je n'ai pas trop de problèmes mais
c'est vrai qu'en
f3 j'ai pas cavaler là on se mange pas
alors on peut faire ajuster procès
hélas ce pion aussi en l'air en hébreu
mais tout vote manger ya aucun problème
de joie pour faire nul on reste dans des
cas
il reste treize moutons donc ce match ok
lui avec des noirs par des résultats on
voit en bullet ya beaucoup de voitures
piétons et gabourey
[Musique]
et tu vois que la même mais même sans
argent il dit les traits il est très
très serré ce qui est très tendue vers
cette
soirée une soirée milonga donc
maintenant c'est ça qui veut faire
mentir vous le mériterait en tout cas il
est bien il n'ya bien coup avec son coin
y avait plusieurs fois ce thème là dans
la barque dans les musiciens
car chaque photo doit être loué en fait
un super court on va pas très souvent le
football a plutôt rogesa et des métaux
sur 930
millions le feu scellé sa critique de
qualité donc ça arrive il veut mater
mais il a raison parce que oui il a un
fou camaro qui pour l'instant être fait
par le poids de 4 mesdames la kabbale et
d'y arriver ces travaux est de 6 on est
un c4 le plus qui bougent le voit il ya
des choses
donc en tout cas on voit ça rime qui
tire qui les pose sur la table quant à
elle son foulard il est là un câble tout
repenser canon qui rend la gamme date à
laquelle ce raid j'ai pas échec et son
frangin et choc d'apprendre
et dix jours après jours et c'est parce
qu'avant de la qualité là c'est
peut-être qu'ils craquent à l'ail calcul
c'est de prendre un peu ses 5e prise
fukui aux échecs tu apprends donc ce qui
n'a pas été simple non à chancelade ils
croyaient peut-être pas parce qu'on
s'était bien et gagner un pion vous
aurez la colonne de winch n'a pas les
juger de m mais bon qu'est ce que c'est
très chaud red bull est en plus si la
fatigue aussi donc je crache tant que ça
m'a l'air bien c'est juste un gros si
vous voyez un ton de plus pour les noirs
mais
pas mal de jeu qui peut se passer alors
on le croit les pions les
rallonges et 4 restées en argentine
moi j'en ai plus de 2 ou 3
500 suiveurs
parfois un simple d'un point à 5 il fout
comme de manière hyper risquer à dire à
chaque fois il prend des décisions crise
à waimes est bon et la dgd qualité se
pose que fois jeu français bons moments
ici ils méritent un
pour sa ténacité pour tout ça c'est
vraiment un très bon c'est le krach h je
prend 1,6 kg 4 à la forme
il n'a pas vu c'est dommage parce que ça
donne ça peut tenir encore
des trous quand même 500 pas plus pour
toutes parts il est sain qui peut
arriver quel point ça tient clou alors
qu'est ce qui va tomber fou proche si
c'est cher donc ton talent fou renvoi
chute qu'elle me réponde à faire deux à
spa qui est projeté
il a une chance soul axa gagne pas
directement je n'ai pas de découvertes
ses fils
et bien pas de copains
bien pour les bleus il ya un ton plus
grave c'est un cauchemar comme un
feuilleton pas bouger ça et je sais car
il prend en charge 7 qui menaçait des
fois c'est à dire des tarifs dits faut
que je trouve un gain de 10 secondes et
diada pas si tu cherches des échecs ça
ne marche pas du coup il a décidé de
manger tous les pions mais se fait
contrer comme à l'écran h stade c'était
possible encore aulas il se fait contrer
ces terribles taille a pas eu de chacun
voilà la fourchette n'ont été que fait
courir de la partie oui mais là ça
qu'elle
ne sait pas c'est pas comme ça en plein
ces banques ont fini encore et encore il
ya peu pour les erreurs sont possibles
ici mais c'est très dur pour dire à qui
va hériter de la gagner mais un pion qui
t'aiment qu'à l'aller on pousse le pion
les chocs ce dernier 3 non on continue
attention maintenant un chien dangereux
forcené nargue n'ont fait une change pas
les armes il n'a pas confiance la finale
je pense qu'elle était nulle je sais pas
confié que voilà tout échec on va se
permettre comme les devants
l'habilitation aux fouilles à plus
d'échecs a plus rien j'ai dit à ma femme
athée
je
croyais à toi ok alors il huit minutes
donc je pense que ça n est pas encore
rené ans pour ce matin sa partie dure à
la minute
il faut par contre doit gagner deux
parties absolument l'annulera pense
s'appelle enterré 1 je pense que vanessa
peu l'intérêt
incroyable peut-être partir il était
complètement gagnant tenir tous les
risques il s'est fait contrer ben kessou
il est là aussi un franchement
c'est un beau match c'est un beau match
[Musique]
c'est un beau match
il faut qu'ils y aillent à tout prix
c'est la
balle de match pour sa première balle de
match pour elle ce n'est
bien qu'ils aient terminé je pense
du choléra il a envoyé le pion b il a
sacrifié des vies un pétard dans ses
matches précédents il n'hésite pas à
sacrifier un funambule est mal lotie
beaters et ouvrir les trois cavaliers à
6 du coût
ou g4 il promit joue vraiment de manière
hyper
tous passés gélules est il ajouté
après il trouve beaucoup beaucoup de 2
elle sacrifie tout la série les parent
tirage là je pense que c'est trop
de façon quasi les beats parmi eux
de problèmes cardiaques étaient encore
pantech s'est joué dans la dernière
partie devra peut-être qu'un sera pas le
cas je pense parce que là je pense à
celle à laquelle l'art de perdre la face
il percevra il a trois parties a gagné
en six minutes en sept minutes ça va pas
le faire à moins qu'ils ont en face
d'eux qu'ils arrivent à commencer dans
la partie les pratiques sont
les chronos
bien sûr c'est une habitude du système
et puis c'est un joueur qui regardait
tout regarde
voilà comment donner c'est maintenant ou
jamais là c'est une bonne question
justement quoi
oued en seconde attaque
j'avoue que là bordeaux sous la normale
et stoppe pas jolies choses quoi
je veux écrire à ce rythme c'est bien
joué dans brothers
elle doit jouer très très vite
maintenant là ils seront à enchaîner
il faut ré sur envoyer 2 et commencer la
partie avant que le chrono soit lancée à
sa partie 45 contre les poissons
la faune est parti de la guns égard
c'est la première partie
de celles là
des sacs de sable ils répètent ils
rêvent pas fait il y avait foule et ses
choix oui aucun mal et funky et pour
couper cet amoureux des
trois
ans d je sais plus
qu'est-ce des quatre tout cas ça perd
généralement
par amour tu vas avoir un très bon du
match là ou pas peu importe l'âge ou
quoi oui sa jauge est celle où pas grand
chose pas le gros line quoi ouais parce
que la partie avec lui on devait gagner
ça me prend bien c'est le module à gaza
m en
saut qui n'échangent pas toutes les
pièces
[Musique]
peut se racler la gorge sereinement
maintenant c'est ce qui fait de multan à
ses six filles
d'amd car pour le moment ils me font
toute une pièce kamal point je suis peut
être une menace attention la
55e tour c'était à boncourt s'est
installée c'est génial ce n'était pas
les joueurs
mais c'est normal le poème tu as et que
ça finit là comme 58 minutes et que du
coup ils piquent mpo vraiment parce
qu'il sait quel chrono et du coup les
grades plein de choses effectivement
obligé à taipei une pièce non pas il y
avait l'idée 3 j'avais le 3 et 3
comprend des huit
manches et à la tour ça va très que fout
des
400 places est complètement gagnant
un fantôme intérieur il ya des pièces
avaient fini la relève cette fille adam
bien fait ce coup il ya échec la
tf s'est dit fort
bien comment les rosiers infragard à
signer et à bord des bacs et en reprise
allait de soi qui à mes yeux d'un
puissant qu'il était viable dès
maintenant
pour la liberté plus elle s'est
complètement rayons mais il reste trois
minutes chrono je pense c'est faisable
ont ils pu venir parce que il faut
qu'ils finissent là et qu'après ils
demandent à celle là ouais mais après il
aurait trois minutes après gagner
l'autre performance égale
mais bon s'il est un poil shore on va
voir en tout cas
il faut qu'il la gueule
dans ce cas tu rêves c'est bien sûr
aller acheter cash six fois et c'est
fini
un vaisseau à quelques el cheikh un
casque
j'aime pas ça il va assister
ce que je déteste je veux tu étais sa
salle en salle c'est ça méritait
franchement je ne
sais bloc est bloqué parce qu'il est en
campagne avec 59 secondes mais bon étant
que tous ont ils véritablement salue
donc il a trois minutes pour gagner la
rive sud partiel et commencer une autre
et
[Musique]
ils restent ici 2040
ok donc là c'est possiblement mais elle
a pris une partie c'est environ trois
minutes ça dure et c'est aux îles peu
stressé un
voilier
sera un exploit s'ils arrivent à la
guinée celle là avec les enfants
continuent une pression énorme sur son
regard ce très beau pour le
terminer domec médecine
il a rejoint
la ville et dans la zone d'une pression
et tu vois ce qui ce qui est insolite
d'un bijou celui qui fut son match il
essaie de ne pas se laisser
parasiter vraiment garde ses pièces il
brille par ses tresses en finale à
casser le centre
combien de temps une minute 58 hockey
ouais ça devrait la partie
c'est passionnant ses cheveux ses shows
parce que tu à l'entraînement qu'ils
veulent tous la seconde régate il s'agit
de jouer bon il faut que ça ring and dès
la 5eme une chose
est sûre tu as les gares d'arrivée du
train
qui jouent pour la main attendu la
réserve est sûr c'est que j'ai cinq
peut-être
aller tu vois pas le match
à cinq manches 7-5 c'est gratuit
27/01/2010
là mais je pense que ça je pense que ça
finira pas regarde déjà des assauts à
soit 20 secondes
ça va être la dernière partie par
méchanceté ni bon c'est fini parce que
il va tomber déjà donc t'as pas rond
gratuit ils resteront
il arrive ça arrive qui compte 112
enfants jouent à définir
et si fait
il ya pas de connexion ou connaissent
pas c'est quoi
il reste onze secondes pour gagner
il faut une bagarre il a presque pas le
chrono sur les bastides tomber je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé terrible
terrible 7 stand match
ouais
ok saut il a été quand même
impressionnant ce marseille là il a très
bien joué franchement ils méritent mais
ils démarrent il a d'abord été bien
mauvais signal barça je pensais qu'ils
auraient pu aider car il a souffert
bah ouais c'est un peu ça va très vite
dans tout ce match comme ça
c'est terminé
s'est terminé 1 c'est fini
le temps que tu arrives à 0
c'est officiel un il va gagner enfin un
match
donc on va trouver du coup
ouais c'est un gros match que tu vois il
est la sarine a franchement
non mais quand moi tous les matches que
j'ai vu le match je t'avais dit un
contre guietsou que je les ai pas vus il
est pareil qui permet des connexions ça
m'était pas continue mais le match
contre contre rapport franchement
j'étais impressionné j'ai trop kiffé et
j'ai trouvé fallait deux joueurs est
vraiment super match et pas de ceux là
bas il est très joli aussi prestement un
beau match que j'en ai marre des joueurs
qui s'envoient dans la gueule
jusqu'au bout bon bien fait jusqu'à
la dernière
non vraiment c'est bah ça c'est dommage
et c'est pour ça que tu vois c'est dans
le jeu et prend tous les risques finale
de dame coupe bat pour dire que je parle
d'un point pas même la boue mais tu vois
juste toi le smic c'est ce que mauzé par
rapport au format
2 ans qui va les gagner mais je te dis
dame jeu de boom au revoir
dommage il va tchèque que le temps soit
bien non je me laisse tomber aucun
monter au cas où s'achevait fin de match
car c'est
ce qu'ils vont recommencer annonce
bien un joueur qui ont ils sont repartis
résoudre parce que
je suis parti parce qu'ils créent dans
les oreilles
du coup bah écoute
on va rejoindre je peux vous mettre un
petit peu le bracket
donc du coup première demi finale donc
on à sow qui se qualifie
avec pas score 15-14 un point d'écart et
qui va rejoindre du coup le vainqueur de
la deuxième demi-finale maca mouradi
milian qui aura les du coup jeudi à
23h30 par française dégâts donc je sais
que cette armée nous on sera là donc
essayer de venir nous soutenir dans
cette dure épreuve
donc donc jeudi soir 23h30 vous aurez la
deuxième demi finale
donc bon je pense qu'elle me favori
nakamura points parce que
ça peut être plus serré mais bon je
pense bas serait une grosse surprise que
ding sortent vainqueurs en tout cas ma
part c'est tout con vu ce que j'ai vu
là on n'est pas sûr de qui était
meilleure
si le match avait commencé le mardi
al preuve c'est qu'il a joué à moitié de
son
jouet la moitié du match ce lundi est à
moitié mardi cas de gros problème de de
sarry dans ce match
bon en tout cas les gars merci encore
d'avoir suivi ce match
c'était vraiment un réel plaisir de la
chanter avec samy et
et donc je vous je vous redis à
jeudi jeudi dans deux jours le jeudi 16
si jamais vous voulez voir les réactions
des joueurs vous pouvez sur la job vous
avez pas marre pièces comme
international c'est possible et vous
parlez
et puis sinon bah oui on vous dit vous
souhaite une bonne nuit il ya une bonne
nuit si à jeudi et à jeudi par tous bien
yes bonne soirée à tous